Tim Ferriss: Dr. Williams.
Good to see you, sir.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, thanks man.
Thanks for having me.
Tim Ferriss: And I thought we would start
with a personal story, not your personal story,
but a story of Deirdre Lehman.
Could you tell us who this person is, how
it fits into your story?
But let's begin with just a description of
Deirdre.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Absolutely.
So Deirdre is, I think, maybe in her 50s,
60s, female, in Bay Area, who has suffered
from bipolar disorder much of her life, and
pretty successfully treated for the mania
side of things over the years.
Had a psychiatrist taking care of that part
in Marin, and happened to slip into this pretty
severe depressive episode a couple of years
back.
Guess it's been, maybe like four or five years
now.
And her psychiatrist had actually gone to
see a talk that I gave at this mood disorders
day, the year before.
And we were talking, it was really early on,
when we were working on a rapid-acting neurostimulation
approach.
The psychiatrist had heard the talk and then
her patient fell into this really bad suicidal
depression.
And so she reached out to me to treat her,
and I got on the phone, I'll never forget,
it was a Wednesday.
And I got on the phone with her psychiatrist
and she was telling me symptomatically how
bad off she was.
And I was like, "I don't think we can treat
her at outpatient.
She's way too ill.
I think she needs to go in the inpatient hospital."
So essentially, gave her some information
on how to do that.
So I see her the next morning and she's in
really bad shape.
Tim Ferriss: What does that mean?
Does that mean like she's —
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How did that show up?
Dr. Nolan Williams: When people are at the
level where they definitively need to go into
the hospital, they're not really totally communicative
anymore, and they've got some cognitive issues
sometimes.
So in her case, she couldn't look you in the
eyes.
Look at the ground and she was doing this
rocking thing, which you can see in pretty
severe depression.
It's kind of this catatonia overlap symptoms.
She's at the very end of the spectrum, one
of the highest severity patients we've ever
treated.
So she was like, a score of 50, on the moderate
side of 60, very, very severe, and just rocking
and not really talking.
And the husband was counting everything.
And she had bipolar one, so she was hypomanic,
I think or manic two weeks before and then
dropped into this very, very severe depression.
So it was her daughter and the husband, and
they're sitting in the room with me and they
want me to treat her, and I say, "Listen,
it's Friday, we go Monday to Friday.
You have to find a way basically to keep her
well from now until Monday.
And that means…"
Tim Ferriss: And by well, you mean safe?
Preventing self harm?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So keep her not having a suicide attempt basically
from now until Monday.
She's very suicidal.
And I said, "You're going to have to take
every knife.
I don't think any guns, but gun, chemical,
scissors, everything out of the house, all
of it has to go.
And you guys have to be on a 24-hour watch
until Monday."
And so Monday morning rolls around and we
bring her in.
And the craziest thing, we had an error, a
repair on the motor threshold coil, which
is the coil you use to get calibrated on the
intensity, and it shorted out the device and
blew the capacitor bank up on the first stimulator.
Tim Ferriss: Blew your flux capacitor.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Yeah.
At 7 a.m.
And you can't imagine how stressful that was.
So we had a second machine, and I'll tell
you about this later.
We were running this trait, hypnotizability
modulation study, and it was over at the scanner,
so it was pretty far away, and these things
weigh like a hundred pounds.
So I had to send my team over there, run over
there and grab it, bring it over.
And luckily we were able to get her going
and treat her with a second machine.
And she was in really, really bad shape that
morning.
And by five o'clock that afternoon, she was
basically normal.
And the next morning she was totally zeroed
out and completely normal.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning no suicidality?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Meaning no depression,
no nothing.
She looked like any person walking the street.
Totally normal.
And that was in 24 hours.
We've seen this with bipolar patients quicker.
It'll happen really quick for a bipolar one
patient.
You can get it done sometimes in a day.
Tim Ferriss: Just for clarity, by "Get it
done," and don't worry people listening, we're
going to define terms and get into all this,
but you're talking about accelerated TMS?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, we're talking about
accelerated TMS.
So our rapid-acting neurostimulation approach,
we're able to get people out of these states
and into normal mood, and in short periods
of time, generally 2.6 days on average for
major depression patients, but it's quicker
with bipolar we've seen, especially with bipolar
one patients.
So she was totally out of it in 24 hours.
And I remember it was right around July 4th
or something.
And so the whole team left.
And I guess we'll maybe talk about caffeine
later too.
So my wife and I were like big Philz Coffee
fans, and so I'll never forget this either.
So we go down to the Philz Coffee in Palo
Alto after I saw them.
And I'll never forget it.
Clark Lehman, her husband, also went to Philz,
didn't know I was going to be there.
And I look over and this guy's just kind of
staring at me, and I was like, "Hey, how are
you?
Good to see you again."
I just saw the guy 10 minutes ago, and he's
like, "I still don't understand what happened."
And it makes sense, to take somebody from
the worst you've ever seen them mood-wise
to normal in such a short period of time was
remarkable for him.
And it ended up being that after that period,
they actually went out and really were helpful
with a lot of the philanthropy that led to
all the trials being funded and ultimately
the clearance, and Clark and Deirdre really
were advocates and have continued to be advocates
for this to kind of get it out into the world.
And it was totally based off of that experience
of basically him feeling helpless and going
from that to feeling like it was all solved.
And I think she went maybe a year completely
asymptomatic, ended up needing to get retreated
again at some point, but gets these little
touch-ups here and there and is able to stay
well ongoing, and, as they tell me, depression's
not her problem anymore.
And so that's good.
She's a great illustrative case of what this
can do and I think what the promise of it
can be.
Tim Ferriss: What I'd love to talk about next
is not necessarily direct mechanism of action,
but I'd love to hear you just explain a snippet
that I pulled from your conversation with
Andrew Huberman, which was a very good conversation.
Specifically it was about, and I'm not going
to use the right terminology here, so bear
with me as a lay person, but the sequencing
or abnormal/pathological sequencing of activation
or activity in different parts of the brain.
So I don't know if it's the anterior cingulate.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: I think you know what I'm alluding
to here.
Would you mind just explaining that?
Because it was something that I had never
been exposed to and I found it deeply fascinating.
And I'll just also mention this context for
people who are listening to this, that part
of what is deeply interesting to me about
a number of the different tools and modalities
that you explore in depth, is not just the
speed of action, but the durability of effect.
Super, super potent combination and very unusual,
from what I can tell, combination of things.
All right.
So as far as the sequence of activation goes,
could you explain what I'm referring to?
Dr. Nolan Williams: We published a paper in
the Proceedings of the National Academy of
Science, I guess it's been about six months
ago now.
So one of the former research track resident
postdocs in the psychiatry program at Stanford,
Anish Mitra, who's now junior faculty, was
working with Karl Deisseroth and I during
that training phase.
And Anish had this interest in a specific
way of looking at brain imaging, particularly
this type of brain imaging called resting-state
functional connectivity MRI.
And so resting-state functional connectivity
MRI has been around for a long time.
The resting state part of it is basically
tell the person sit in the MRI scanner and
let their mind wander.
So that's kind of the resting state or the
default mode, however you want to think about
it.
And functional connectivity, what that means
is it's the brain regions that have blood
flow that is time-locked with each other.
And so essentially these connected brain networks,
the blood flow will go up or go down in those
areas in a time-locked fashion and blood flow
is —
Tim Ferriss: By time-locked, you just mean
at the same time?
Dr. Nolan Williams: At the same time.
Tim Ferriss: Correlating.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
And so why blood flow?
Blood flow is a surrogate of electrical activity.
It's hard to see electrical activity deep
in the brain.
People see it at the surface of the EEG, but
with MRI, you use the blood flow as a surrogate
of the electrical activity, and it makes sense,
if you're using glucose in a brain region
using that network, then you need to have
cerebral auto-regulation, so the blood vessels
increase and they dilate more blood goes into
that area.
So it's just like a response to increased
activity.
And so you have these increases in blood flow
that are supposed to represent electrical
activity that are in different separate nodes
in the brain, and they come on roughly at
the same time.
And we've known that for a while.
Anish got very interested in this idea that
the timing of the blood flow is consistently
temporally offset between these nodes.
So slightly, that people ignored it for a
long time, but he was able through using various
math, able to show that there's a slight offset
of the timing such that one brain region slightly
comes on before the other.
And that's interesting because that infers
some level of causality.
And so instead of the whole network coming
on at the same time, maybe it's just one area
and it's signaling the whole network on, and
it's so quick that you see it as all like
this, but really it's more like this, if that
makes sense.
It's coming on all at the same time.
But from this network node kind of turning
this one on, turning that one on or something
like that.
Tim Ferriss: The lead domino matters.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's right.
The lead domino.
Exactly.
And so in the case of mood, it looks like
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex, the area
that's involved in control, precedes slightly
the cingulate cortex.
In our normal healthy control population,
essentially nearly everybody had that directionality.
In the depressed cohort, 70 percent of them
had it flipped where the cingulate was temporally
in front of the dorsolateral, but not everybody.
And if you just had that information, then
you wouldn't know what to make of that.
Why is it some people and not others?
But what was interesting is when he looked
at the folks that had it versus the ones that
didn't, the ones that had it were the ones
that were responsive to our — when we'll
talk about what SAINT is and the rapid-acting
neural stimulation approach in detail, I guess,
later.
But the folks that responded to SAINT responded
to this rapid-acting TMS approach were the
ones that had the biomarker and the ones that
had no change, did not have the biomarker
and looked like a normal healthy control.
And the signal on the post scan flipped to
look normal in the folks that responded had
the biomarker, and then their brain changed
after.
And so the post-scan looked just like the
pre-scan on the folks that didn't clinically
change in the normal healthy controls.
And so we see this sort of test all the time
in medicine.
10 people come into the primary care doctor's
office with blurry vision, urinating a lot,
drinking a lot, headache.
A lot of those folks probably have diabetes,
but not all of them.
Some of them have migraine headache and need
glasses and some other things, and it looks
like the diabetes presentation.
But when you go and do the blood sugar, the
blood sugar is normal.
And then the folks that have elevated blood
sugar that look like they have diabetes, you
go and you give them a diabetic medicine and
then it normalizes.
So the blood sugar after looks like the blood
sugar of a normal healthy, and it looks like
the blood sugar of somebody that symptomatically
presented but didn't have diabetes.
And so it was nice to see this and we're replicating
this now.
We have money from the National Institutes
of Health to do that, but this idea that we're
able to have a test that would change, and
the same thing that signals that there's an
abnormality is the thing that changes later.
And that's more rare in psychiatry to be able
to have all of that line up.
So we're pretty excited about that and hope
to see it.
It does replicate in the larger population
of patients, but as a conceptual idea, it's
an important conceptual idea, this general
idea of being able to use neuroimaging or
whatever it is, EG, whatever it is, to type
different people that are presenting with
similar symptoms and be able to say, "Okay,
you're going to respond to this and not this,
or vice versa."
And I think that's part of what we need for
psychiatry, right?
Because people spend just so much time in
their lives trying to find the answer, and
we don't really have any tests.
Tim Ferriss: Trial and error.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it's a lot of trial
and error.
Tim Ferriss: It's like pharmaceutical ready,
fire, aim, in a sense.
And this raises, I guess just a meta observation/question.
Perhaps you could just discuss this briefly,
which is, it seems to me like there have been,
and this is part of the impetus for us having
this conversation, part of the impetus for
me in the last, let's call it half year, paying
a lot of attention to accelerated TMS, which
is there have been these dominant paradigms
in certain types of, let's call it psychiatric
treatments, for things like depression — treatment-resistant
depression.
And it seems like a very dominant paradigm
for a period of perhaps several decades has
been these chemical imbalance theory of psychiatric
disorders.
So you have a serotonin issue, therefore we're
going to treat it in these following ways.
You have such and such an issue, so we're
going to give you SNRIs.
And then like you said, it's a lot of trial
and error to figure out what works.
And even if something works, it may often
only work for a period of time.
So it seems to me, and I want you to absolutely
fact check and correct everything that I'm
saying, but that part of the reason that the
research you're doing and that others are
engaging in is so fascinating is that it presents
an alternative paradigm through which you
could look at certain disorders, right?
Like, oh, wait a second.
Well, maybe this person's car, when you turn
the ignition, is just tripping things in the
wrong order.
And if that's causal, we could try to address
that and then maybe that addresses what we
might've otherwise perceived as a chemical
disorder.
I have a lot of follow-up questions, but is
that a helpful way to think about this?
Or what would you add to that?
Dr. Nolan Williams: I think there's been,
I would argue three eras in psychiatry, what
friends of mine have called psychiatry 1.0,
2.0, 3.0, and the first era was this era in
and around Freud.
And this idea that it was a content issue
and a life experience issue, which is partially
true.
It's not that that's not true, it's just not
complete.
And so then the solution is a content solution,
a initially psychoanalysis all the way through
to modern forms of psychotherapy.
The limitations of that led us to psychiatry
2.0, right?
This idea that we serendipitously found the
first antipsychotics, first antidepressants,
and we were able to deinstitutionalize primarily
schizophrenia patients out of inpatient asylum
stays with these drugs, which kind of flew
in the face of this being a content issue.
Tim Ferriss: What was the first antipsychotic?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Thorazine.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to say Thorazine.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: How was that — I don't want
to take you off track.
So keep track of where we are.
We're at 2.0.
How was it serendipitously discovered?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I think, if I remember
correctly, I think it was they were trying
to — it was like an antibiotic or something
like that, and they were trying to develop
that drug out for something completely unrelated
and happened to give it to some patients with
schizophrenia.
And they had a dramatic improvement.
Tim Ferriss: I would love to read a book that
is just a collection of case studies like
this, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It's like sildenafil, Viagra,
it's like for angina or whatever.
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: And then the male patients are
like, "Why aren't the male patients sending
their meds back?
Oh, wait a second."
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Here we go.
Fascinating.
All right, so right.
So Thorazine and the serendipitous discovery
of — oh, wait a fucking second.
This seems to not necessarily negate, but
certainly render incomplete this pre-existing
paradigm.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's right.
Tim Ferriss: And then where does it go from
there?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
So then I think, to your point, there was
this accumulate kind of accumulation of assumptions
around, well, if we're moving all of these
chemicals around in the brain, then it must
be that there's a deficiency or an imbalance
or whatever.
And that I think led us to recent history
where there's quite a bit of prescribing of
oral antidepressants and all that stuff.
And the third era, this circuit era that I
think we're in now, and I'd argue we were
entering in 10 years ago, but I think we're
pretty squarely at the beginning of now, flies
in the face of that.
If I can take a patient as severe as Deirdre
Lehman, get her out of it in a very quick
timeframe and looking normal and holding that
for a long time, and there was no chemical
exchange, there's nothing that went into her
system, then it gets you into this newer way
of thinking about it.
It's a circuit problem.
The useful thing about this framing, one,
it's seemingly consistently true in the sense
that through all the various modalities seeing
these differences, but more importantly, it
lets you integrate past ideas into that concept.
Drugs act on circuits, therapy acts on circuits,
but focal neuromodulation is a really direct
way of acting on those same circuits.
And so from a patient standpoint, I think
it's very empowering because we're not saying
to the patient there's something inherently
missing or too much for you in the sense that
you're constrained to having to take these
exogenous chemicals to stay well, but rather
there's a circuit, there's a miswiring, misfiring
sort of problem.
And if we can reroute that information, then
you can feel well.
And I think that there's a level of empowerment
that comes with that.
One of the things that patients always tell
me after they get well with some of our stimulation
approaches is that they kind of look at it
and say, "Well, I may get depressed again,
but I don't think I'll ever get suicidal at
that same level again, because I know that
I've got a way of getting out of it and it's
my own volition to choose to do that, and
it's something I can tolerate and I feel normal."
Tim Ferriss: So I'd like to highlight that
last part because, not that I'm the world's
foremost expert in suicidal ideation, but
as someone who came very close to offing himself
in college and really just by a series of
lucky events ended up not fulfilling that,
it's the hopelessness.
For me and for a lot of people, it's the feeling
that nothing can fix this.
I am broken.
I'm permanently broken.
There is no option other than trying to silence
this voice in my head.
And the only way I can think of doing that
is by ending my life.
But once you see, once you experience, even
more so, something that alleviates that, especially
with any type of durability, doesn't need
to be forever, but some type of durability,
and especially if it's rapid-acting, then
you feel like you have a plan B, and that
is incredibly empowering.
Let me ask you a few questions.
The first is this type of neuromodulation,
is that synonymous with a term that I came
across, I don't know who coined it, it's a
nice term, electroceuticals, or are those
different?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I think it's a broad
— yeah, it's part of that broader term of
electroceuticals.
Yeah.
And so what we had done, I don't know if this
is a good time to get into it.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
What we had done with what we called SAINT,
or Stanford Accelerated Intelligent Neuromodulation
Therapy, is that we came up with a way of
reorganizing conventional TMS, which had been
around for some time, reorganizing it in time
and in space.
And so with conventional RTMS, it had developed
in the mid-'80s, first used as a therapeutic
within clinical trials by my mentor Mark George
when he was at NIH in the mid-'90s and approved
by the FDA in the mid to late 2000s, it utilized
average skull positions to find an average
spot to stimulate, which at the time, given
the technology that was available, that was
the right call.
Right.
Tim Ferriss: Can I pause for one second just
to give some additional context?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What does TMS stand for?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, so transcranial
magnetic stimulation.
So it's this —
Tim Ferriss: And it was originally developed
for what?
Dr. Nolan Williams: As a motor probe by Tony
Barker in the UK.
And the idea is this idea of Faraday's law.
So Faraday's law is this idea that you pulse
a magnet, you pulse a magnet, you can generate
current and electrically conducting substances.
So if I take an electromagnet, if I take a
TMS machine to the beach and I try to pulse
the sand, nothing's going to happen because
sand is not, as you know, electrically conducting
at all.
It's an insulator.
And so if you put a TMS coil or any electromagnet
next to a wire, a copper wire, or speaker
wire or whatever, you can generate current
in that wire.
If you put the coil on the head, it will bypass
the skin, scalp, skull, and induce current
in the electrically conducting substance in
the brain, the kind of brain tissue.
And so you're able to selectively turn on
cortical neurons without really interacting
with much of the rest of the head.
People do feel something because of the nerves
in the scalp, but your brain can't feel anything.
So that's like scalp nerves.
And so if you, as they did in the '80s, just
kind of send a single pulse, it doesn't really
change the brain, but you can probe the brain.
So I could take that coil from the mid-'80s
and I could put it over my hand representation,
make my thumb move, I can put it over my wrist
representation in my brain, I can make my
wrist move.
And it's organized in this stereotyped way
such that essentially the head face area is
closer to the ear and you can march up to
the midline of the skulls, such that when
you get to the midline, you're able to actually
move the foot and the leg.
If you have a certain kind of coil, you can
do that.
And so you can actually probe the entire motor
system and make all of it move without having
any volition to it.
Tim Ferriss: Question: what is the value of
this probe?
Dr. Nolan Williams: So the value of a probe
itself is just as they thought —
Tim Ferriss: Figuring out the mapping.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it's a mapping exercise
initially.
Where is everything?
Is it the same in everybody, is it consistent?
And they wanted to have a way of doing that
non-invasively.
Penrose and others had been doing this invasively
as neurosurgeons for a hundred years, I guess
50 years at that point.
And so they wanted to be able to emulate what
the surgeons could do in epilepsy patients,
they're doing epilepsy surgery non-invasively.
And then what folks realized over the next
10 years is we can send a signal into the
brain that's like Morse code and basically
send this signal to change the excitability
of the brain.
And we can measure it if we do it in motor
cortex by how much the thumb moves with a
set amplitude out of the machine.
So if I get X movement where I can make from
stimulating here, I can make the thumb move
X amount, and then I send this Morse code
signal onto the brain to tell it to tone down
or to kind of be less excitable, and then
I send that same intensity back in.
The thumb will move half as much, right?
And so you've toned down cortical excitability.
If, instead, I get this measurement of X,
and then instead of putting in what we call
inhibitory or de-potentiating stimulation,
we put in excitatory potentiating stimulation
into the brain, and we do that and then we
measure again, it'll be 2X.
So we knew by the mid-'90s that we could actually
move around how excitable the brain was in
these normal, healthy, control volunteer motor
cortices, and so the aha moment for Mark and
his team was this idea that depression at
that time on PET scans, on spec scans, was
this kind of hypoactivity, hypometabolism.
Tim Ferriss: Meaning lower?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Lower, yeah.
Yeah, sorry, yeah.
Lower activity, lower metabolism of the prefrontal
cortex, right, where the prefrontal cortex
just isn't as active, isn't as robust as it
is in normal healthy controls.
And so, he had this idea, "Well, could we
use this excitatory stimulation to drive up
activity?"
And so that was the aha moment in the kind
of first version of this.
But they were super careful.
There'd been some seizures in the early days
from trying to figure out how all this works,
and so they wanted to do a stimulation approach
that wasn't going to have much in the way
of risk.
And so, they had this once a day, very extended
protocol, and because of the mid-'90s, it
was very hard to get cheap brain scans on
patients.
And so this idea that they were going to have
to use average coordinates to target it, and
so they get average skull measurements, and
then they would do a low dose sort of approach
once a day and do that out for weeks, and
then it'd extended out to months.
And so, the original TMS trials and the original
approval was this less efficient version that
basically utilized kind of a low efficiency
signal into the brain, and used kind of average
coordinates to place the coil.
Tim Ferriss: So, average coordinates meaning,
just by clumsy analogy, "We can't take an
X-ray of you, but we do have a hundred other
X-rays that seem to indicate roughly this
is where you have your fracture.
So we're going to aim at those coordinates."
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's right.
Yeah, that's right.
Tim Ferriss: And the once-a-day protocol,
I've heard the number 36 from somewhere, but
is it somewhere in, generally, like the 30
to 40 session range?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's exactly right.
Tim Ferriss: So we're looking at, let's just
call it for a placeholder, 30 to 40 sessions,
one per day.
And to perhaps not necessarily conjure an
image, but remove an image from the minds
of some listeners.
They may be thinking, "This is A Beautiful
Mind.
This is somebody chomping down on a wallet
or a piece of wood, getting electroconvulsive
therapy."
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yep, yep.
Tim Ferriss: These are not the same thing.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it's actually the
opposite, right?
So the goal of electroconvulsive therapy,
or ECT, which has been around for 100 years,
is to produce a therapeutic seizure.
It's effective, it's associated with, and
some people with autobiographical memory troubles,
it's pretty underutilized as a treatment in
psychiatry because of these issues, because
of particularly One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest and that story, and that movie culturally
has actually had an impact on ECT.
And it's one of these things that's kind of,
for a lot of patients, that last ditch resort
because of the concerns around the side effects.
TMS is different, right?
You're not trying to induce a seizure.
In fact, you're not trying to have any sort
of change in cognition.
I always tell patients it's really boring,
and so we have Netflix running in the background
and people have their Netflix movie that they
keep watching every day.
And it's basically just, once folks get used
to it, it's just part of a routine where they're
sitting there and watching their show or whatever
it is and the stimulators turning their brain
on.
And, yeah.
Unlike ECT, there's no anesthesia, there's
really no need for anything.
You can do this in an outpatient setting.
But the old forms of TMS are extremely slow.
You can't use that in a psychiatric emergency.
And so this is something that happens over
a couple of months, and it's tricky for some
people.
If you're a working person and you have to
do TMS during, conventional TMS during business
hours, and you basically have to tell your
boss or sneak out of the office or whatever
it is and go do an hour and a half during
the middle of the day, during standard bankers
hours to be able to do this, and it's hard
to do that over a couple of months.
And it doesn't address these kind of high
acuity emergencies.
And so we got very interested in this idea
of can we, like I said earlier, reorganize
the stimulation in time and space?
Space being, can we personalize it to each
person's brain?
I can talk about that in greater detail.
And then, can we compress these six-week courses,
in this case, into a single day?
So that's why Deirdre was able to get well
in a day, is we gave her a whole six-week
course in a day.
Tim Ferriss: You gave her how many sessions?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's 10 triple dose
sessions.
And so it's like 30 total equivalent sessions
in a day.
And so the FDA cleared 600 pulses of ITBS
once a day, five days a week, for six weeks
in 2018.
And so we give —
Tim Ferriss: That was for a major depressive
disorder?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That was major depressive
disorder.
And so we give a triple dose every session,
so 1,800 pulses.
And so, after 10 sessions, you've got the
equivalent of 30 sessions worth in that first
day, and you do that for five days.
And so, people are getting the dose equivalent
of seven and a half months worth of TMS in
five days.
And what we found is, surprising to us that
it was this linear, is that you just pick
up remitters as you progress through the days.
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by remitters?
Dr. Nolan Williams: People who completely
lose all of their depressive symptoms to a
level that is within the normal range.
So, they're rating at the same level as somebody
who's not depressed.
And we can get people there on an average
of 2.6 days, and we're able to do that by
personalizing the target and then being able
to deliver treatment into that target, a lot
of treatment over a short period of time.
And so what's useful about that is somebody
can be in a really pretty bad state on Monday
morning, they can take a week off a vacation
and may end up being on the inpatient unit
or whatever it is, but they can go out, get
this done, and get back to work in a timeframe
that's actually reasonable.
And that was really our goal.
How do we get people acutely out of these
high acuity settings and into a state of wellness
quick enough that it doesn't make a major
impact on their lives?
Tim Ferriss: May I add one thing to that?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Which is,
Tim Ferriss: I've had a number of friends,
and I've certainly heard of many cases where
people with certain professions, airline pilots,
firefighters, police officers, there are many
more, will not report any type of mental health
issue because they will be suspended, in a
lot of cases, or relieved of duty.
They'll be forced to take time off.
And in a case like this where you have a compressed
protocol, there's the possibility of taking
PTO or taking a week off and doing this treatment,
whereas like you said, doing it during banker's
hours over months is going to be highly visible,
right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And until the entire system changes,
which is going to take time if it happens
at all, this would be an incredibly attractive
alternative protocol —
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — if it were to work.
So please continue.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, and that's the way that we thought about
it, right, is can we take folks who need to
get well quickly.
I mean, we had people in conventional TMS
courses where they started, they're in really
bad shape, they lose their job halfway through.
Maybe they get better at the end of it, but
it took so long.
And so it's one of these things, if we can
compress that up and get them well in a short
period of time and get them out of it, it
gets people back to their lives and it has
a low impact on it.
Tim Ferriss: I know I'm interrupting a lot,
but the threading of this I think is important.
So we can sort of foreshadow something that
is going to be on the minds of a lot of people,
which is, what are the downsides, what are
the risks?
So my question is, was it easy to get the
sort of ethics board approval to compress
all of this into a much shorter timeframe?
Dr. Nolan Williams: I was able to make a compelling
case to the IRB and then eventually to the
FDA around safety.
We give 90 percent of the resting motor threshold
that's depth-corrected for atrophy.
So if it's an older patient, they have more
prefrontal atrophy, then you can increase
the intensity based off of that difference
in depth with the motor cortex.
But essentially, what their brain is getting
is 90 percent of the resting motor threshold,
which is kind of a calibrated number that's
based off of these motor, these TMS induced
motor movements.
It gives us a sense of how to dose the stimulation.
Tim Ferriss: May I translate that briefly?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sorry to interrupt.
So I'll show a bit of my hand here, which
is I've undergone two separate weeks with
different hardware, different protocols, because
I'd never want to talk about things like this
unless I've put myself in the spaceship and
been the monkey shot into space.
Which doesn't mean at this point I am a proselytizer
100 percent for the treatment, but I find
it very compelling, at least for investigation.
So, to just explain since I recently went
through this, each morning, or certainly on
the first morning, but on multiple mornings
in my case, they will test your motor threshold.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Right?
And that could be a finger or a hand, it could
be a foot, and they'll watch movement really
closely.
And then based on that, determine the sort
of dose that will be delivered throughout
the day during these sessions.
And in my case, it was once an hour for 10
hours a day.
Dr. Nolan Williams: So it's just a way of
getting the intensity that you need.
And so we know that 90 percent, meaning sub
motor threshold, there's never been a TMS-related
seizure for that kind of sub motor threshold
intensity.
Even giving multiple sessions a day or whatever
it is, there's never been an event like that.
It's always been at a higher kind of intensity
of the stimulation in the moment, if that
makes sense.
So the amount of magnetic field that's being
put out in proximity to the brain.
And so it seems to be much more related to
that than it does the amount of pulses that
you receive in a day.
And so I was able to lay that out to the various
regulatory bodies and show the evidence that
that threshold is really the threshold where
risk goes up.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
It's sort of the magnitude of the strength
of the pulse, not the frequency or the density.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Exactly.
It's more about the intensity in this case,
and less about the density or the amount.
So, laying that out, it was acceptable, and
various parties deemed it to be non-significant
risk, and they let us proceed.
Now this is FDA breakthrough status, FDA cleared,
and all the way through all of the regulatory
processes.
And so it's kind of an on-label approach these
days.
But back then, I had to make a lot of those
arguments.
And knock on wood, we still haven't seen any
seizure.
Tim Ferriss: How many people would you say
at this point have gone through well-designed,
accelerated TMS?
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's definitely, I'd say
more than four or 500 between trials.
We have trials where they're ongoing and I
don't know what the clinical outcome of those
trials are because I'm blinded to them, but
I do know that AEs, right, we can know what,
and we don't have any serious adverse events
in the sense we haven't had anybody have a
seizure yet.
So that's good.
But what you do see is headache.
People will have a headache.
It's usually from the, not everybody, but
a fair percentage of people.
And it's mainly related to the coil-activating
skull nerve, scalp nerves, and basically kind
of turning the facial musculature on.
And that actually goes away over time.
So, in the long-term, you can actually see
a reduction in migraine headaches and you
can see a reduction in pain, all that sort
of thing, And people actually have an antinociceptive
effect.
Tim Ferriss: Anti, excuse me?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Anti-pain effect.
Tim Ferriss: Ah, pain.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What was the word you used?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Nociceptive?
Tim Ferriss: New one.
All right.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And so, you can actually have an anti-pain
effect, and the reason why we think that happens
is because you actually —
Tim Ferriss: Anti-pain, meaning it could help
with chronic pain or something like this?
Dr. Nolan Williams: — at least acute experimental
pain.
There are some chronic pain studies.
You can see that you release endogenous opioids
from stimulation because you can actually
use opioid blockers and block the anti-pain
effects of TMS.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow.
Dr. Nolan Williams: So, there's this whole
kind of pharmaco stimulation thing that people
are looking into.
A buddy of mine, Joe Taylor, who's at Harvard
now, did these studies when he was an MD/PhD
and he was able to actually show that there
is this release and that you can kind of block
it with co-administration of opiate-blocking
drugs.
But yeah, that's the idea is that there is
some acute potential headache risk, and people
can get a little fatigued from this.
It's like fatigue, more like you ran a marathon
instead of depression related fatigue, just
from kind of being there all week.
Tim Ferriss: Look, N-of-1 here, but seems,
I spent a lot of time talking to folks as
kind of my job.
My experience was, headache for sure.
I was hesitant to take any type of Tylenol
or medication for that just because, and this
is, again, as a naive lay person.
But I was like, well, if you do take NSAIDs,
if you're doing, say, weight training that
can inhibit some of the adaptive response.
I'm not sure we fully understand what the
hell's going on here, so I'm just going to
deal with the headache.
It was tolerable.
I mean, you could feel it.
The fatigue was the fatigue that you might
feel if you were cramming for your final exams
every day.
It was not the fatigue of apathy and anhedonia,
the difficulty or impossibility of finding
joy in the things you'd normally find joy
with.
That type of fatigue is, characteristically,
it was very different.
It's more like, yeah, you just crammed for
20 hours to try to nail your finals because
you didn't prepare, and you're going to do
that every day.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's the feeling.
Tim Ferriss: Question for you, then.
We're going to get to the results.
I want you to discuss the results of SAINT,
but I think before we do that, it's important
to maybe describe this patient population.
Is it fair to say that you're seeing, it'd
be an exaggeration maybe to say the worst
of the worst, but you're dealing with patients
who have had multiple failed interventions.
So it seems like that's important to kind
of keep in mind if that is true.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
And so, in our randomized control trial, people
had an average of nine failed, nine years
of the current episode.
So, they were depressed for nine years on
average, straight before they came into our
trial, at five plus or minus two med failures,
and they had a lifetime load of depression
of about 25 years.
So, these were folks who've been depressed
with multiple episodes or very long episodes,
and they tried a lot of meds to get out of
those episodes.
These are not mild cases, right?
These are folks who've kind of been through
it for a long time.
And interestingly, going back to the study
that we talked about earlier with the flipping
of the signal, that flipping of the signal
was correlated with higher MADRS scores.
And so, the more —
Tim Ferriss: MADRS is the assessment?
Dr. Nolan Williams: I'm sorry, yeah.
Higher depression scores.
And so, the higher your depression rating,
the higher likelihood you are to have that
signal from the data that we collected.
And so, and that's what we've seen, right?
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
And this switching, just to tie it back to
what we were talking about, is that sort of
having the wrong lead domino, or if you have
a car where you're trying to start the diesel
car without heating the coil first?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's right.
Tim Ferriss: Type of situation.
Yeah.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah.
So, it's that directionality.
And so, that's what we've seen.
Folks that are at that kind of more in-stage
sort of depression seemed to be more responsive
to this.
And I think that's because, in those cases,
you're really correcting this pretty dense
brain signaling problem if that PNAS work
replicates.
And what we've also seen is folks that do
really well with dorsal later at least are
folks who have a pretty impaired attention,
and so they actually score up on the concentration
item of the depression scales.
And so that was something we observed earlier
on, that if you're saying you can't read a
book anymore, you can't really follow a recipe
book to cook your favorite meal or whatever
because you just can't attend to it, then
your likelihood of getting better from this
is higher.
Whereas folks that are more on the kind of
obsessive/depressive side of things that don't
complain as much about cognitive problems
and concentration problems, but more about
they're just ruminating and kind of obsessing
on things, we've found that inhibiting the
right frontal pole, orbital frontal cortex,
so stimulating here, and we have OCD trials
to do that, is pretty effective at shutting
that down.
So it's more of a shutting down than a turning
up sort of intervention.
So, some of it's actually where the illness
intersects with the brain anatomy intersects
with the symptomatic presentation to try to
derive the best spot to stimulate for those
folks.
And we have some early studies now where we're
trying to use brain imaging to actually sort
folks into buckets neurally, to figure out
which target makes sense for their symptomatic
presentation.
Tim Ferriss: Based on their personalized fMRI
scans?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So I think this would be a good
point, and we'll mention this again at the
end, but maybe you could mention any open
trials or if people would like to consider
enrolling or they know someone who might want
to become subject in the study.
Is there anything you'd like to mention?
Dr. Nolan Williams: So we have a number of
trials that are ongoing at the Stanford Brain
Stimulation Lab, so it's bsl.stanford.edu/clinical-trials.
And you can go on the website and then there's
a screening portal and people can go on and
fill out their information.
And essentially, we have trials for anhedonic
depression, we have trials for standard severe
treatment-resistant depression, obsessive
compulsive disorder, borderline personality
disorder, patients who also have depression,
bipolar depression, and other pilots, some
addiction work that my collaborators are working
on, and so folks have that range of symptomatology.
Happy to have folks come through and screen.
And it's all free, which is nice.
So it's all basically funded through these
trials.
And yeah, we're excited to bring people in
and see if it makes sense for them to work
with us on this, and it's a couple of week
commitment.
Tim Ferriss: What did the results, or what
have the results looked like with SAINT or
slight permutations of that, and how do they
compare to, let's just say more conventional
treatments for these same conditions?
Dr. Nolan Williams: So in our original pilot
study, 90 percent of people experienced remission
at the post.
Tim Ferriss: 90 percent?
Dr. Nolan Williams: 90 percent, yep.
In the randomized control trial, it was 79
percent of people transited through remission
at some point in the four-week follow-up.
What's interesting is it's not all at the
same time point.
So if you look at time point by time point,
it's in the 50 to 60 percent range.
And the reason for that is because there's
this, colleagues of mine at Cornell, Conor
Liston and others, have replicated this finding
that there's a subpopulation of patients that
actually has a slower time to remission.
And we've seen those too.
Folks will lose their suicidal ideation, will
actually peak their antidepressant effect
at one month.
It's usually in older adults, and that's what
we've seen is basically it's only in 50-year-olds
and above.
We haven't seen that —
Tim Ferriss: That sort of delayed remission?
Dr. Nolan Williams: — that delayed remission,
yeah.
But if you're putting together 22- to 80-year-olds,
you're going to have some of these folks.
But what's interesting is TMS is also a probe
of the system.
If you kind of ignore the kind of normal rules
of how to define remission, and you just ask
the question of who crosses through, 79 percent
of our active group crossed through, 13 percent
of our control group crossed through.
And that tells you something, I think, about
the neuroanatomy, that probably something
in the 70 percent of folks have this dorsal
lateral cingulate problem.
And then that was a version of that thinking
was seen in our PNAS signaling paper too,
about 70 percent of those folks had the flip
in the signal.
And so my suspicion is that there's a subpopulation
of people who don't have that, who have some
other diagnosis.
It probably looks a lot like depression, but
it's probably a different neuroanatomy.
And we've seen this sort of phenomenon happen
in medicine before.
We used to cluster all the Parkinsonism together.
So, there's lots of reasons that Parkinsonism,
some of those reasons are idiopathic Parkinson's
disease in the kind of classic sense, the
way —
Tim Ferriss: What does idiopathic mean?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Just that it's kind of
this spontaneous happening of Parkinson's
disease.
That's the core Parkinson's syndrome that
we think about in Michael J. Fox and others.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Nolan Williams: And then you've got other
things that look like it, progressive supranuclear
palsy, Lewy body dementia, drug-related Parkinsonism.
And so, we used to kind of lump —
Tim Ferriss: Parallel to your diabetes presentation
earlier?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, exactly, exactly.
So, we forever lumped all these folks together,
and it really took the UK Brain Bank and being
able to link, in that case for Parkinson's,
link Parkinson's pathology to symptomatic
presentation.
Tim Ferriss: What is the UK Brain Bank?
I've never heard of this.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
So, it's like a brain — I mean, there's
lots of brain banks or brain donation entities.
Tim Ferriss: Physical brains, or are we talking
about scans?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Physical brains after
death, post-mortem donations.
So, there's a lot of ways you can donate.
If you have a neuropsych disease, you can
donate your brain to science.
And so, a lot of Parkinson's patients donated
their brains to this brain bank to try to
understand what it is.
And what they found was, with a deep clinical
phenotyping before death, right?
And so then folks, you had this kind of deep
phenotyping, and then after death, they were
able to —
Tim Ferriss: Sorry, what do you mean by deep
phenotyping?
Dr. Nolan Williams: — like a deep, kind
understanding of the symptomatology, right?
So basically, does this person's tremor, did
their tremor happen on one side or both sides
at the same time?
Tim Ferriss: How do things present?
Dr. Nolan Williams: How do things present?
Tim Ferriss: In an observable way?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's right, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: In the same way, just folks,
so you have genotype, phenotype, right?
So, this would be a similar idea.
Okay.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Yeah.
So basically, what they found was, clinically,
people that have the kind of standard Parkinson's
disease typically tend to have a presentation
of unilateral onset illness, right?
Where one side of the body or the other is
much worse from a Parkinsonian standpoint
than the other.
And it's actually very common for people with
Parkinson's to present where, if it's a leg
onset Parkinson's or foot's dragging, or tremor
just in one hand, right?
And that's actually what you would expect
from normal Parkinson's.
If it's really symmetric, it's less likely
to be that and it's more likely to be something
else.
And they figured that out from essentially
the brain biology and forming that, being
able to link up substantia nigra problems
they found on autopsy with symptoms.
And so I think we're at the beginning of an
era in psychiatry to be able to do the same
sort of thing, to take what's lumped together
as depression or anxiety or whatnot, and to
be able to parse it into a lot of different,
what we call biotypes, or people think about
as endophenotypes or whatever these kind specific
kind of flavors of that symptomatology.
Some linked with a very specific brain physiology
or brain functional neuroanatomy, such that
you can say that this depression type one
needs this treatment.
Depression type two needs this treatment,
and so on and so forth.
And so that's really, from my vantage point,
the future, right, is being able to really,
at an N-of-1 level, at a single-patient level,
be able to figure out something about their
brain and then use that to help to prescribe
what the next step is for them.
And if we can do that, we can also cut time,
right, because we can go straight to the effective
treatment for people and cut all the time
around diagnosis.
I mean, there's —
Tim Ferriss: And it's not just time, it's
risk, right?
In a lot of these cases.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Absolutely.
It's time, it's risk from potentially the
wrong treatment.
It's also risk from waiting.
Tim Ferriss: It's cost, potentially, also,
right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's also cost.
Yeah, So, as you know, right, there's a period
of time where the diagnosis is uncertain,
and then there's a period of time where the
treatment is uncertain, right?
So, for bipolar depression, the average length
of time it takes to diagnose somebody with
bipolar disorder from a depressive episode
onset, so they come in with depression and
depression's their primary presentation, seven
years until you get them.
Tim Ferriss: Geez.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Right?
Tim Ferriss: It's wild.
And then, that's just to get to that point.
Now you're on the right realm of medications
or whatever.
Now you're talking about, in year seven, you're
having to spend whatever it is, like three,
five, seven more years trying to find a solution.
So you could go from being 25 years old and
having this be your first depressive episode,
and you're still trying to figure out what
you're going to do about it at 40, and you
see these patients.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I'm just imagining you're reaching into a
dark closet and there's what you think is
a screw head, and you're just trying different
tools, but you're not allowed to touch the
screw head.
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's it.
Tim Ferriss: Versus let's flip on the light,
take a photograph, and then go find the appropriate
tool for the job.
Just a couple of follow-ups, the numbers that
you're mentioning, the remission rates, the
people who pass through, so to speak, how
does that compare to frontline conventional
treatments right now?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah so I mean, oral antidepressants,
so there's a study called STAR*D, it's been
an interesting year for STAR*D in the sense
that some people have reanalyzed that data
and there's open questions about what the
percentages are as far as what percentage
of people make it to a remitted state after
going through this algorithm.
But, essentially, STAR*D started with a pretty
low side effect burden, oral antidepressants,
citalopram, and then transited through higher
risks like SNRIs and psychotherapy and lots
of other.
Tim Ferriss: What's the trade name for escitalopram?
Do you know what people would know it as?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Lexapro.
Tim Ferriss: Lexapro.
Got it.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
And citalopram, Celexa.
So those drugs, and then you go to SNRIs,
like Effexor, venlafaxine, and then into the
tricyclics and monoamine oxidase inhibitors.
And so people would go through this algorithm
and then they'd pop out on the other end after
five or six or seven different treatments.
And then they'd ask the question of, after
people go through all of this, what's their
remission rate?
So that number's kind of been called into
question, but essentially when you get into
med four, which is roughly where insurance
used to start to pay for TM, conventional
TMS, conventional TMS would beat that pretty
well, almost double, compared to you're talking
about lithium or thyroid hormone, things like
that.
When you start getting into that step, and
conventional TMS would beat that.
When you get to those next even more severe
steps, you start to lose efficacy with conventional
TMS.
So you go from a remission rate of around
30 percent with conventional TMS down to about
16 percent when you get into the higher treatment
resistance levels.
That's the levels that we ran our trials on,
which really that where people normally get
about 16 percent remission with conventional
TMS.
That's where we were seeing those numbers.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just repeat those numbers
where you're seeing what numbers?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
So in our open-label trial, 90 percent in
our randomized control trial, depending upon
how you look at it's in the 50, 60 percent
at each time point or 79 percent if you're
asking did people transit through remission
at any point.
Tim Ferriss: Versus 16 percent.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Versus 16 percent.
Tim Ferriss: And this wasn't a head-to-head.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's not a head-to-head
thing.
Tim Ferriss: But just so people have some
means of comparison.
And in terms of pharmaceutical interventions
at that point?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Very low.
I mean, you're talking about sub-ten percent
efficacy.
This is around where electroconvulsive therapy
is thought about, this kind of therapeutic
seizure thing we were talking about earlier.
That's got about a 48 percent remission rate,
but it's not fast either, and you definitely
can't work the day you get it.
And there's this autobiographical memory thing,
so you're talking about a conventional TMS,
like a one- to two-month commitment, and then
quite a bit of risk for side effects there.
You've got ketamine, which produces about
a 30 percent spot remission rate with a single
infusion, and that goes up as you administer
more ketamine treatments with the IV ketamine
forms.
But as you go from a single infusion to what
they did in this New England Journal paper
that was published a couple of months ago,
like six treatments over a couple of weeks,
it starts to accumulate more time.
And so we're able to, from my standpoint,
we're able to get the most bang for your buck
the quickest and with the least kind of interruption,
and I think people's ability to do stuff during
that time.
But there are other things, ketamine, psilocybin,
and other psychedelic drugs that I think you've
thought about and talked about on this show
before that are also coming over the next
couple of years.
Tim Ferriss: A few follow up comments and
questions.
You mentioned a number of things, borderline
personality disorder, bipolar as two examples.
Part of the reason that I'm so interested
in neuromodulation right now, accelerated
TMS in particular, although I'm also interested
in other things that I know less about like
focused ultrasound and so on, which we might
get into if we have time, is that many of
the conditions that would be screened out
there would be exclusionary criteria in, say,
a psychedelic-assisted psychotherapy trial
—
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — are eligible for this type
of treatment.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Which is incredibly interesting.
There are people also who might have something
that is more common, extreme hypertension,
some type of ocular issue where, physiologically,
psilocybin shouldn't technically pose a risk,
but if they have a lot of panic, rapid heart
rate, etc, there might be complications, right?
Elderly patients, etc.
So part of the reason this entire realm of
treatment possibilities with neuromodulation
is interesting is because these tools could
be available to people who would not be good
candidates for some of these other things
that you're mentioning.
What I'd love to ask you about, because this
has been one of the questions that has just
stuck in my head, is the topic of delayed
remission.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Having these patients, I can't
remember the number, I was looking at some
of the charts, maybe it was three or four
people out of N-of-16, I can't recall.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's right.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, there we go.
Who had this remission at week four.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Or something like that.
How do you explain this and why is it older
patients or does it seem to be older patients,
and how do you relate it to a few things?
So, in the case of, say, SSRIs, some folks
also have this, a lot of people, delayed onset
of benefits.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And then you have ketamine, this
is going to be a bit of a sloppy question,
but I'm sure you can clean it up for me.
Then you have ketamine, which is very rapid-acting,
and I have heard, I do not have the credibility
or the means of parsing all of this.
Okay, well, ketamine acts directly on NMDA
receptors.
Seems like maybe SSRIs do that, but in a very
indirect way, and that explains the delayed
benefits in some patients.
Don't know if that's true or not.
Don't know if I'm even wording that correctly.
How do you tie this to or not the delayed
remission?
Because I'm just like, how does that even
work, right?
I'm like, okay, if you put a drug in someone's
head and it triggers a cascade or maybe it
triggers some type of exceptional neuroplasticity
that then shows the fruits of that at weeks,
whatever, two, three, four.
But I just cannot figure out, I can't come
up with, I haven't been able to figure out
a plausible mechanism for the accelerated
TMS and that delayed remission.
How do you think about that?
Even if it's speculation.
Dr. Nolan Williams: And it would be speculation,
but I think, so we've only seen in older adults,
we know that the brain plasticity in older
adults goes down as a generality.
And there are lots of metrics about why folks
think that.
As you talked about earlier, it's cramming
for a test, you're actually sending a memory
signal into the brain.
So the stimulation pattern you're sending
into the brain, this kind of Morse code is
really a "Turn on, stay on, remember to stay
on" memory signal that's going into the brain.
You're just basically taking the hippocampus,
the part of the brain that's involved in memory
and that signaling that comes out of there,
and you're playing that back through the prefrontal
cortex in a way to try to tell the prefrontal
cortex to "Turn on, stay on, and remember
to stay on."
I think part of what's going on is, because
that older brain is a little less likely to
have flexibility/plasticity, it takes some
time for the signal to fully lay its tracks
into the brain.
We don't have any sort of biology to back
that up yet, but what we're doing right now,
we haven't analyzed this data yet, is we're
actually scanning people every single day
and we're scanning people multiple times out
to the month.
NIH funded one —
Tim Ferriss: By scanning you mean fMRI?
Dr. Nolan Williams: fMRI scanning.
Yeah, yeah.
So we're actually getting 10 scans spread
out over —
Tim Ferriss: It's a lot of coffin time.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's a lot.
Yeah, yeah.
People have been very cool about this.
And so we've been able to with that, we think
that we're going to be able to potentially
spell some of this out.
Why are these delayed remitters happening?
But my suspicion is that it's probably a plasticity
related issue.
Interestingly, ketamine and TMS may have more
in common with each other than one would initially
think.
A lot of the TMS effects are probably, in
part, glutamate-related, as is ketamine.
And then as we talked about earlier, there's
an endogenous opioid release from TMS.
We've done some work with opioid-related mechanisms
in ketamine.
There's probably a confluence of not one neurotransmitter
system, but an orchestra of neurotransmitter
systems that are being affected across these
interventions.
It's my suspicion that that's probably what
needs to happen in order for these treatments
to be effective.
And our old views on this kind of chemical
imbalance sort of 1990s view of one neurotransmitter,
one neurotransmitter receptor sort of problem
in the brain is way too simplistic and that
it's probably a lot more complicated, as one
would imagine, a lot more complicated than
that.
Tim Ferriss: Outside of accelerated TMS, if
you're looking out, say, over the next five
years for rapid-acting, potentially durable
antidepressant effects, what other tools or
molecules or treatments are most interesting
to you?
Dr. Nolan Williams: We have a paper coming
out soon in Nature Medicine on looking at
at ibogaine as a potential treatment for,
in this case for military traumatic brain
injury, but a lot of these folks had depression,
generalized anxiety disorder, and PTSD.
It was an interesting, that was another interesting
story, so I was approached back in 2018 by
a professor, a senior professor at Stanford
who was tapped by some folks to kind of find
somebody who'd be willing to partner with
a non-profit called VETS at the time who were
sending, and I think you've interacted with
Amber and Marcus Capone a little bit.
Tim Ferriss: I have, yeah, I interviewed Rick
Perry and Rick Doblin two years ago at their
Veterans Day fundraiser.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I was there, I remember.
That was an interesting one, yeah.
We partnered up with them and I had to again,
go to the Stanford IRB and ask them for another
edgy — and you have to give the Stanford
IRB credit.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just spell out IRB?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Oh, sorry.
Institutional Review Board.
It's the entity that reviews all research
protocols at institutions.
This is the kind of governing body that's
in place that's been around for about a hundred
years that essentially is a non-conflicted,
uninvolved group of senior professors that
look at your proposed research and then determine
if it's ethical and safe and answering the
questions that you think you're going to answer.
And so just going to them to talk through
doing accelerated TMS and saying we were able
to talk to them about doing a study where
people would come to Stanford, knowing in
the IRB, knowingly agree to them, then going
down to Mexico to take an illegal-in-the-US
root bark extract that's been utilized for
millennia in the country of Gabon and related
areas in central West Africa.
As you can imagine, this was not a quick turnaround,
nor should it have been for the IRB in the
sense that I had to convince them this was
science worth doing.
Tim Ferriss: At that time though, is it fair
to say you're the TMS guy, or was it in the
air that you also had an interest in exploring
something like an iboga or an ibogaine?
Dr. Nolan Williams: People knew that I was
very open-minded to things.
I'm a pragmatist, right?
I mean, for me, the patient's the most important
thing.
I have this view of psychiatry that it's going
to look like in-patient cardiology in 20 years
where we're going to use drugs, we're going
to use devices, we're going to be able to
figure out what the best thing is for that
patient.
To your point, some of these things are good
for different problems.
I think that was known that I was open to
that.
We'd just been running this ketamine mechanism
trial, so I was tapped to look at this and
a couple other people too.
I found out later they'd gone to, like, a
lot of people.
Apparently, I was the only person that was
willing to do this trial.
I felt kind of special back then, and then
later realized —
Tim Ferriss: "Oh, wait a second, I was on
The Bachelorette and I didn't even realize."
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I was on The Bachelorette
and I didn't realize it.
Essentially, yeah, and The Bachelorette was
a tricky one.
We ended up reluctantly agreeing to this.
Admittedly I almost pulled out a couple of
times because ibogaine has this street knowledge,
and academic knowledge, that it has a death
risk.
Right, it has a one, roughly one-in-300 risk
of death from Torsade de pointes.
This arrhythmia, fatal arrhythmia that can
happen with certain cardiac-acting drugs,
and it works through this, what they call
HRG potassium channel.
Other things do this or like FDA cleared like
cancer drugs and arrhythmia drugs, that'll
do it too, so it's not —
In context, it's like something that happens
with lots of different drugs that we use.
But I think there was somewhat of a stigma
and a bias around particularly an addiction
drug.
Folks had been trying to get this through
the FDA and NIH and whatnot in the '90s, Howard
Lotsof and others, and it was a very complicated
drug.
And I'd known about it since residency.
I'd read about it.
I thought that it was like, "Wow, this is
the most promising anti-addiction drug on
the planet."
But I'd thought it was completely unstudiable,
and I kept doing my other stuff.
Tim Ferriss: At that point, how did you come
across ibogaine?
Where did you find it?
Dr. Nolan Williams: In 2012, 2010, you know,
I think —
Tim Ferriss: Would this have been early Deborah
Mash stuff or?
Dr. Nolan Williams: No, no.
I come across this book Breaking Open the
Head by Daniel Pinchbeck.
Tim Ferriss: Pinchbeck.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Yeah.
He was a big, I think he wrote for The New
Yorker or something, and I was stuck.
I was going kite surfing in South America
and I was stuck in the San Salvador airport
and there was five English-speaking books
or something.
I picked this book up in the airport.
Tim Ferriss: What?
That was in the San Salvador airport?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Randomly, right?
I got a hold of this book and read it waiting
on my flight, which was like eight hours delayed
to get to Peru.
And so essentially, yeah, he just lays the
whole thing out.
It was very interesting.
He talks about his own personal experience
of it, and then I read a lot about it.
And there was some work that folks like Ken
Alper and others had published on the case
report level outcomes, but then also the cardiac
problems.
So then I figured it was kind of unstudiable.
And then, yeah, in 2018 I was approached and
was asked to do this trial.
And so we went to the IRB, spent a year back
and forth, and right when they were about
to, they approved it, COVID hit.
So we were actually supposed to start when
COVID happened, and it paused the whole thing.
It took a while to get it back online, but
it was actually the quickest recruiting study
I've ever run.
We got 30 people done in eight months.
Tim Ferriss: Now is that because of the category
of potential death of despair?
I mean, is it because of the patient population?
Were you dealing with addicts?
Dr. Nolan Williams: So the patient population
was, and that was the unique part about this,
it was veterans with traumatic brain injury,
some of which were alcohol use disorders,
so we used to call alcoholism, but more than
a third, I think 13 or 14 people out of the
30.
But everybody had TBI, a lot of them, most
of them had depression, most of them had PTSD.
We were running this trial, I put my best
neuropsychology postdoc on it and a couple
other superstars, and it was running in the
background and I was like, we'll get this
into a pretty good journal or whatever, thinking
we'd see some people get better, some not,
whatever.
I remember I was asked to give a talk about
it at a very prestigious university and asked
the postdocs, we just wrapped up the immediate
post and asked the postdocs to put the data
together and we have data to present for them.
They showed me the clinical outcomes, and
I was completely blown away.
It was way better than I think we anticipated,
very consistent improvements in basically
everybody.
Some people would lose it before the month,
but most people held it and they're holding
it out to a year now.
I was floored.
I actually told them to delete all the code
and start the analysis over.
They had to have done something wrong in the
math, which is always fun.
The postdoc always, they kind of say yes,
and look at you, "You just ruined my weekend."
And so we did it again and it was the same
exact findings.
So I was wrong, they were right, they had
done it the first time, essentially really,
really striking.
And like I said, by the time this will come
out, Nature Medicine will have published this.
Tim Ferriss: Somewhat prestigious.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Somewhat!
Top five biomedical journals in the world.
Tim Ferriss: It's like being nominated for
best picture at the Academy Awards, I mean,
scientifically speaking, right?
It's up there.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's up there.
It's a nice deal.
It was very surprising that, for me, that
they were going to be open to publishing an
open-label paper, which historically you're
going to publish in that kind of a journal,
like a randomized trial.
Tim Ferriss: Just for clarity's sake, for
folks listening, so open-label means no placebo
control, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And also to just rewind for a
second, I want to mention to people that for
accelerated TMS, how do you know it's not
placebo effect?
You mentioned the control group, but that's
a sham treatment.
You're basically, people feel like they're
getting a treatment, but they're not actually
getting the proper treatment.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, in that case, you
want to ask a blind guess.
And that's actually been a big — so I was
going to get into here a big problem with
a lot of the psychedelic trials and why there's
a lot of criticism for a lot of the psychedelic
trials is that they kind of know that the
blind guess is going to be highly skewed.
So there was one trial where they did psilocybin
for alcohol use disorder.
I think it was like 99 percent correct blind
guess rating, so the P value was highly significant.
In our same studies, to my great surprise,
our blind guess was chance.
Tim Ferriss: Could you explain what do you
mean by blind guess?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Mr. Smith, who —
Tim Ferriss: These are the experimenters.
Trying to guess who is in which group.
Dr. Nolan Williams: This is the patients trying
to guess what they got.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
"So, Mr. Smith, you just wrapped up your treatment,
which treatment did you get: active or sham,
what's your confidence…"
Tim Ferriss: Got it.
Dr. Nolan Williams: "...in what you got?
And so what we found, which is really interesting
for SAINT, was that I didn't know what people
got, but I talked to some of these people
and I heard some of this.
So it was really interesting.
Patients who'd gotten totally better and they'd
say things like, "Yeah, I just got lucky with
placebo this time," they ended up getting
active.
And then the folks that didn't get any better,
that they got sham, would say things like,
"I'm not even good enough to respond to the
active treatments."
So it was confusing enough for them where
they were making the wrong guess 50 percent
of the time, which is what you're looking
for, is about 50 percent error rate.
And it's a coin toss.
Tim Ferriss: Sidebar on that, I know this
is very kind of staccato the way that I'm
trying to hold this conversation, but having
gone through two weeks, different hardware,
different practitioners, etc., and having
had a lot of conversations with technicians
and so on, it also seems like for some people
it takes a while for their narrative to catch
up with the hardware upgrade.
In the sense that they say, "Well, maybe I
got lucky," or "Maybe I don't really feel
that much," and yet their assessments are
improving and/or their significant others
see dramatic changes, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's true.
That's not specifically a TMS effect, or a
SAINT effect, or accelerated TMS effect.
That's true, I think, for a lot of treatments
you see that, I mean, I've had calls in since
our data's been out on ibogaine where I've
had people call me and say, "Hey, Mr. or Mrs.
so-and-so, they look amazing."
And they're not, they don't think they're
any better.
And so I think you can see it across the board,
psychedelics, neuro mod.
There's a certain problem called alexithymia
in about 25 percent of people with treatment-resistant
depression.
Tim Ferriss: Alexythymia.
Dr. Nolan Williams: And so "A" meaning without,
"Lex" meaning the ability to describe, "Thymia"
mood.
And so they can't really describe their mood,
and so they have an inability to accurately
rate their mood.
And the way you know that is —
Tim Ferriss: Alexithymia.
I'm going to use that at a fancy cocktail
party, so, "Tim, how are you doing?"
"Sorry, got alexithymia" "Oh, sorry.
You may better know that as 'Difficulty to
describe mood.'"
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's all right.
Sorry, I'll try to back off on the medical
jargon.
Tim Ferriss: No, I like it.
I'm learning all sorts of words.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it's an interesting
term and it's an interesting phenomenon.
You see this in psychiatric conditions.
People just have a, if you ask them very specific
questions, "Well, when's the last time you've
been sad or thought about anything negative?"
"Oh, it's been a week or two."
"Are you depressed?"
"Yes."
"Well, why do you know that?"
"I don't know."
They just don't know.
Tim Ferriss: It's also like a self-reporting
problem too, I think in some cases, right?
It's like if you ask someone, "How many calories
did you eat yesterday?"
Most people would be off by 30 to 60 percent
or something, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's right.
I think what, the remedy for that is that
you have a clinician rater, and the clinician
rater asks these really, really pointed, very
detailed questions, and then the patient's
able to answer, and then it's a formula to
calculate what that mood rating is, in that
case.
Sometimes it's just off from what their perception
is, but when their kind of meta perception
of the whole thing.
But when you get down to the brass tacks,
they're answering right, and so we've seen
that and that's been true across these problems
and there's ways of constructing trials to
deal with that.
But yeah, we've seen that with psychedelics
as well.
So we went after military TBI and yeah, we
were just really surprised.
And one of the biggest —
Tim Ferriss: And these were all special operations?
Dr. Nolan Williams: They were basically all
Army Rangers, Navy SEAL, former Army Rangers,
former Navy SEALs.
There's been a big cohort of these folks that
have gone down, I mean, some people in Congress
have gone down and done this and have spoken
about it publicly.
I mean, it's this National Defense Authorization
Act, the NDA, I think has just went through
the Senate and the House both approved it
yesterday and it's going to Biden.
So to earmark money for ibogaine for trials,
which is pretty cool.
The military community and some of the government
is pretty aware that this is a possibility.
There's been a lot of advocacy that Amber
and Marcus have been involved in.
My hope is that coming out of a journal like
Nature Medicine that really kind of validates
what we were seeing and puts some context
to what we observed and what we found in our
study, will help to spur more funding and
more focus.
I think the veteran psychedelic angle is an
important one for a lot of ethical moral reasons
and a lot of —
Tim Ferriss: Stuff like a political immunity
bracelet, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's right.
That one.
Tim Ferriss: It's a very important subpopulation
and it's very fortunate that it aligns with
driving forward the research around these
therapeutic tools.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it was super cool
to work with those guys.
Tim Ferriss: And this was a monotherapy in
the sense that it was just ibogaine.
I know that at least in many places in Mexico,
they sometimes combine it.
Well, they don't combine it, but they sequence
it with 5-MeO-DMT at the tail end.
Was this ibogaine alone?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it was ibogaine
alone, and then we had folks come back later
to do the 5-MeO outside of this month follow-up
period.
But the data that we're publishing in Nature
Medicine is just the ibogaine effect.
It was tricky to divorce those two together
because that's what's been going on, as you
know, in Mexico quite a bit.
All the acute out to the one-month effects
are all ibogaine, direct ibogaine effects,
and it's super cool.
And the thing that I found really interesting
about this drug is that it produces what I
think is probably the most stereotyped trip,
if you want to call it, or the psychological
phenomenon that happens alongside the drug
effects.
People will describe this earlier life, autobiographical
replaying of emotionally salient memories
that are kind of epoched in time.
Tim Ferriss: Some people call it life review,
right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Life review or slideshow.
Yeah, exactly.
It's interesting, everybody's kind of got
a different version of what the slideshow
ends up playing out to be like for them.
Some people would say, I found myself in this
room and it was on my TV from childhood, and
all of a sudden it was playing all these things,
or I found myself in a hall of mirrors and
it was playing all these things.
So kind of like the context can be very different,
the mind seems to shape that, but the actual
replay seems to be pretty stereotyped.
Tim Ferriss: Stereotyped, meaning like it's
a pattern that repeats or it is just like
a common characteristic.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's a common characteristic,
and it's closed-eye only.
It's not open eyes, it's not for a lot of
people.
The ibogaine experience is kind of really
around this part, this kind of replay part
that happens.
And from what I have heard, there's kind of
a cathartic re-evaluation of these memories,
and interestingly, an ability to not only
have insights into your own reasons, which
may have been good or bad for feeling or behaving
or doing whatever it was, but also reasons
for they have some insight and the reasons
for the other, which, to me, is the hardest
thing to explain.
It's almost like you knew it the whole time.
Tim Ferriss: Can you say it one more time?
Say the last part again?
Dr. Nolan Williams: When people have this
slideshow or life review, they seem to have
it as a third-party person in the experience.
What is this Christmas Carol, Scrooge, or
whatever, when they go back, they go back
in life and you see —
Tim Ferriss: You become the observer of your
own past experience.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Right?
It's kind of like that.
Scrooge goes back and sees himself as a kid.
He sees himself as when he broke up with his
significant, all that stuff.
It's almost like that, like you're having
a similar sort of thing where I've used the
analogy of Tom Cruise in Minority Report,
where you're able to go back and see these
events.
And what's so fascinating, and why I've said,
and I continue to say I think this is the
most sophisticated drug on the planet, is
that I think that there's nothing else that
can seem to do this, right, where you have
these experiences where you're able to hold
this neutral place, and you're able to have
this sense of where you were and why you did
what you did.
And you have this sense of the other, and
you're able to, I don't know, intuit, empathize,
I don't know what that is, you somehow stored
it at the time and you weren't able to fully
access it and you're able to access it, whatever
that is.
Being able to forgive or to forget or to understand
this person's position as well as your own,
and then seemingly unlock the lock on both
sides and then kind of dissolve the problem.
And people will say, they kind of would work
through all of this.
And there's one veteran would say, "Well,
I went through all this military stuff, and
at the back of the room it was my early childhood
trauma."
And so this idea that, at the core of it,
for a lot of this ends up being a childhood
trauma thing that's kind of buried below all
of it.
And really being able to actually both access
that in a way that you can understand that,
in many cases, the traumatizer was themselves
traumatized and that it's a pattern of trauma
and the ability to kind of resolve it by understanding
and this kind of more meta empathic viewpoint.
And so that's where I think the tool's really
going to be important is this ability to have
what seems to be a pretty profound or atrophic
effect.
We were able to see disability improvements
from traumatic brain injury, but also this
pretty pronounced cathartic reevaluation of
past life problematic memories.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
As I'm wont to do, let me hop in with just
a few comments that we can bounce around if
we want and then a whole bunch of questions.
So the first comment is with the special operations
vets who are friends of mine, what I've observed,
maybe similar to what you're describing, that
is, part of what has contributed to them being
extremely high performers in these high-stress
environments is their ability to tightly compartmentalize,
which they developed when they were traumatized
as kids.
Super high overlap, incredibly high overlap.
Of course, there are many other factors that
contribute to them being the one person out
of 10,000 who doesn't get washed out of training,
being that unbreakable in a sense.
But with those friends, and look, it's a tiny
sample size, but of those friends, I wouldn't
say any of them would claim to have PTSD or
moral injury, like a feeling of having done
the wrong thing.
But the TBI, and this is where I want to lead
into a question, which is not to negate the
fact that a lot of people could have, of course,
meet the diagnoses for complex PTSD and so
on with the TBI.
What makes ibogaine different from some of
these other psychedelics?
And I want to say one maybe place to explore
would be glial cells.
Am I making this up?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Glial-derived neurotrophic
factor, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Glial-derived neurotrophic factor.
There we go.
What makes it different in terms of mechanisms
of action, therapeutic effect, compared to
some molecules people might be more familiar
with — psilocybin or otherwise?
Dr. Nolan Williams: The classic psychedelics,
like psilocybin, as you know, primarily affect
the 5-HT2A receptors.
So there are 5-HT2A agonist, they produce
these kind of classic psychedelic experiences
from largely from that receptor you can selectively
knock out 5-HT2A receptors, you can knock
out the psychedelic effect.
So we've largely thought about this class
of psychedelics in that way.
Ibogaine is a known neurogen, so it produces
a dreamlike state.
Some people call it an atypical psychedelic.
We've elected to use this neurogen term because
I think it more accurately reflects what's
going on in the trip and in the way of perceiving
what it is.
It does have some 5-HT2A action, but that's
probably the minority of the effect.
It affects a broad range of other receptor
systems.
So salvia for instance, is a kappa agonist,
right?
And so there's kappa mu effects, there's NMDA
effects with ibogaine, there's SERT effects,
so serotonin effects.
And then there's this upregulation of BDNF,
brain-derived neurotrophic factor, and GDNF,
glial-derived neurotrophic factor, and both
of those are profound neurotrophic factors
for plasticity in the brain.
The problem is this has been, psychedelics
were thought of as relatively obscure 15,
20 years ago to study.
Obviously that's changed now, but ibogaine
is extremely obscure.
So there were a handful of studies that were
performed and published in good journals over
time, but it's very limited in the data that
we have so far.
So it's hard to give you some sort of definitive
answer of what's going on in the brain.
And so what I can tell you is that it was
a paper published, I think 15 or 20 years
ago, where they took mice and they got them
to self-administer alcohol.
So that's kind of a way of an addiction model
or whatever, an alcohol self-administration
or sucrose self-administration, sugar self-administration,
it's like a way of getting, you can put cocaine
in the water and get mice to —
Tim Ferriss: Modeling addiction.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, exactly.
And so if you give a mouse ibogaine, you can
get them to stop self-administering alcohol.
It's interesting, we saw that in humans that
stopped drinking as well in our study, or
in this case, you could actually drill a small
hole in the mouse's brain, you can inject
GDNF directly into the ventral tegmental area,
the area that produces dopamine for more of
the pleasure-seeking part of the brain.
And it emulated the same effect as the ibogaine,
so this GDNF effect in the dopamine system
at least, and GDNF is thought to regulate
dopamine neurons.
And so I think that that's probably at least
a pretty strong part of it and what makes
it so unique.
But we don't, I always tell people when I'm
talking about this ibogaine stuff, if we gave
one of the big pharma companies a hundred
billion dollars and said, "Don't just re-synthesize
ibogaine, but make a drug that works like
ibogaine," or, I think even some of the classic
psychedelics, but really specifically ibogaine,
I think they'd have a hard time doing it because
we don't have the neuroscience to understand
what's going on there.
And I think it's because it's not a one receptor.
Tim Ferriss: It's not super clean in that
way.
It's like promiscuous.
It's like —
Dr. Nolan Williams: People use that term "dirty
drug," I think it's —
Tim Ferriss: It has the wrong connotation,
but yeah.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: LSD is pretty kind of promiscuous.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I think promiscuous,
I like to think about —
Tim Ferriss: Complex?
Sophisticated?
Dr. Nolan Williams: I like to think about
it like a symphony.
Tim Ferriss: There we go.
Dr. Nolan Williams: You're interacting with
these neurotransmitter systems in proportions
in such a way that it produces this effect.
My suspicion is that it's probably more sophisticated
than we want to attribute to, I mean maybe
not you, but the scientific community wants
to attribute to nature being able to pull
off.
But it's this idea that maybe somehow we have
this drug that just happens to work the way
it works because it's able to interact with
these systems in pretty important ratios or
pretty important kind of simultaneous effects.
And that's really what's driving it.
And that's the part I'm saying it's going
to be hard to reproduce.
I mean obviously Sasha Shulgin and others
were able to take/emulate similar sort of
5-HT2A effects, but I don't even think he
was able to produce an ibogaine-like multi-receptor
sort of symphony like this.
There hasn't really been another drug like
it in this way.
And so trying to think about what that is
and really how to study it's going to take
a new wave of neuroscience tools to be able
to capture all the effects in real time.
Tim Ferriss: I have a symphony of follow-up
questions.
And so I'll give, you can choose, this is
dealer's choice, you're the dealer.
So we could go with and we will get to all
these, but improving the safety profile of
ibogaine, which I should also say I've had
people reach out to me, which is always — can
be very uncomfortable for me, but a friend
of a very close friend, and in this particular
case, someone's sister was a heroin addict
who is now homeless, acting as a prostitute,
living under an overpass.
And the reason I bring up all that level of
detail is that for a lot of interventions
in this case, ibogaine at that point, the
cardiac risk or some of the risks were known.
And there's a question of is this risky?
And the follow-up is compared to what?
And in this particular conversation it was,
well, she could die tomorrow from an OD or
this and the other thing.
So I'm just kind of setting the table with
that.
But improving the safety profile is one question.
Another, because you mentioned the cessation
of, or the minimizing of the AUD, so people
stopping drinking.
We were also talking before recording people
stopping drinking caffeine I guess, or coffee.
Dr. Nolan Williams: We saw that.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Unexpected presumably.
And so my question there, which I sort of
seeded because I mentioned I would want to
talk about this, it's like any overlap in
terms of mechanism around how does this compare
to something like Semaglutide or an Ozempic
or some of the newer gen, I think Mounjaro,
maybe I'm getting that wrong.
And then the last one, and I've been wanting
to ask somebody about this.
So you mentioned 5-HT2A, it seems like some
psychedelics exert effects also on 5-HT2B
receptors.
And if I'm not mistaken, there's some data
to suggest that that can — continued stimulation,
agonism of that B can lead to some type of
cardiac complication as well, some type of
ventricular hypertrophy —
Dr. Nolan Williams: Heart valves.
Tim Ferriss: Valves.
Exactly.
So the question there is do you think that
microdosing, for instance, which has become
all the rage, could that potentially have
long-term negative cardiac effects?
Dr. Nolan Williams: And not to derail too
much, yeah, exactly.
The FDA clearance, the FDA guidance document
for psychedelics that they released actually
on the last day of the psychedelic science
meeting, which is really interesting, specifically
has a section about this issue of cardiac
valvular problems, particularly from these
more classic psychedelics.
The problem with ibogaine is different.
The problem with ibogaine is that it interacts
with hERG potassium channel.
There are a number of groups, folks at Columbia,
folks at UC Davis who have looked at this
and their solution is to modify the molecule
and to affect it in such a way that it no
longer interacts with hERG.
Tim Ferriss: Do you mean noribogaine or something
like that?
Or is it more of a —
Dr. Nolan Williams: Noribogaine, the primary
metabolite of ibogaine that goes after 2D6
is a normal part of the ibogaine process,
has a similar cardiac risk profile.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it does.
Dr. Nolan Williams: So it's drugs that are,
I think they call them like tabernanthe logs
or something, but, iboga logs or something,
I think is what was coined at Davis, but essentially
these are drugs where they try to engineer
off that interaction, which may or may not
have an effect on its brain effects.
I mean generally, and so I want to answer
the question I'm trying to ask, and the question
I'm trying to ask is, does ibogaine help with
certain human illness by modifying the molecule?
It's not ibogaine anymore, it's something
else.
And then you're asking the question, is this
something else help — the view is maybe
it's close enough to ibogaine to do something
similar.
And I've taken a different stance on this
where I've basically taken the frame of how
do you preserve the molecule and really lean
in on the cardiac risk?
Tim Ferriss: How do you put an airbag in the
car instead of redesigning the whole car?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Instead of making it 3an airborne shuttle
or something, I don't know, whatever.
So it's putting an airbag in with a high likelihood
of saving the person.
And so we talk about this in the article,
but essentially all the patients that were
treated received torsades, like IV magnesium
at the start.
Tim Ferriss: What type of magnesium?
Dr. Nolan Williams: So it's like magnesium
sulfate.
So it's basically just like IV bag magnesium.
And so what's really interesting about this
arrhythmia torsades that everybody's worried
about is that the treatment for it per the
American Heart Association guidelines is to
give IV magnesium, which is incredibly safe.
And I've given many times for various things
in the ER and you can just give it to people
and you'll eventually urinate it out or whatever.
And so you can give it, get people through
this risk period, and then they may be slightly
hyper magnesiumic or a little high on their
magnesium in their blood and they'll go out
and everything's all good.
And there've been about a thousand operators
that have gone down to Mexico so far.
And to my knowledge, and we looked into this
pretty significantly, there hasn't been a
single case of torsades.
Conversely, the New Zealand study that was
published a couple of years ago, they had
a death out of 10 people.
And so we are not doing head-to-head, I can't
tell you for sure what the deal is there,
but my suspicion is that if you give, what
is the treatment for the problem you're worried
about before you give the thing that can cause
that problem, then it's much more likely that
you can knock out the risk or significantly
reduce the risk.
It's also about doing it in a monitored bed
setting.
So Tikosyn, T-I-K-O-S-Y-N, is a drug that
is approved for atrial fibrillation and it's
an antiarrhythmic that can be pro-arrhythmic
in the same way as ibogaine and actually has
more risk than ibogaine.
The rates of torsades are higher with Tikosyn,
it's approved, and it's totally safe if you
do it in a monitored cardiac bed.
And so I think that we have to, if we're,
and my suspicion is if we're going to do a
study in the US with ibogaine, we're just
going to need to do it in a monitored cardiac
bed with cardiologists involved.
And I think if you do that, you're good.
I think the trick is between now and when
in theory one could see an approval eventually
from the FDA for this, you're going to have
to think about, well, not just can this place
in wherever Mexico, wherever it is, provide
a good pure form of ibogaine, but what's the
wraparound risk reduction there?
And I think that's what people have to think
about as they think about that, taking on
that level of risk.
It's not trivial risk, though.
It's a real risk.
I think the reason why the veterans that we
studied were so interested in going is because,
as you point out, there's a lot of risks from
not doing things too.
Tim Ferriss: There's also a lot of social
proof in that community now.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And a friend will go down with
their friend to sit in the same room and it's
a tight group, I mean.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's a super tight group
and it's pretty cool.
And I think it's, the reason why I did the
trial ultimately was because my view was there's
no way that all these very high performing
special operators are all going down to Mexico
and taking this thing, which is not recreational
at all, and spending a week down there dealing
with this and then they're not really getting
benefit, they're getting some sort of pure
placebo effect.
It just seemed unlikely to me given how treatment-resistant
and how many things that these folks had done,
how much time they'd spent in the VA hospital
and all that good stuff.
And so that's why we did it.
And what we found was enough of a consistent
finding and this reversal of disability such
that the, well, I can't tell you this works
because I don't have that level of evidence
on it, that the signal that this could work
is really high.
It's the highest of any kind of brain-acting
drug I've been involved in looking at.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Let's talk about the alcohol and the caffeine.
So mechanism of action, I mean, you sort of
mentioned the GDNF in the animal models, the
direct kind of injection.
How do you think about this and does it in
any way tie into what we're seeing with some
of these drugs that are, I guess designed
for type two diabetics, the semaglutide and
Ozempic-like drugs, but they're having such
an effect on various types of cravings that
large box retailers are having to revise,
sort of in a panic, their sales projections
and inventory planning around snack foods
and stuff.
I mean, it's wild to see the societal ripple
effects.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Walmart apparently has
sold less food.
Tim Ferriss: And I have friends who have been
obese effectively their entire lives, never
had an exercise habit, and now they're doing
pull-ups for the first time, which is again,
not an endorsement because I don't understand,
and maybe nobody really quite understands
exactly how these things work, but I certainly
don't, so I'm not yet there.
But how do you think about this, I mean, are
there any overlaps with these?
Are they completely different mechanisms just
presenting similarly?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's a great question.
There's no evidence that there's a direct
overlap in mechanism just because I think
the kind of CNS kind of psych addictions side
of things, people are still in the like, "Is
this doing something yet?"
It looks like it's doing something there,
but not in any deeper than that.
I think we'll learn about that on the Ozempic
drug side of things.
And then ibogaine has been relatively underexplored
from basic science, science and technology.
And my suspicion is, is that is probably similar
enough and maybe some of the same mechanisms
are being enacted because what you're finding
is a similar phenomenon across both instances.
We thought these were diabetes drugs and then
there was a significant weight loss observed,
and then we thought these were weight loss
drugs and then everybody's quitting all their
other habits.
And placebo works by a phenomenon called expectancy.
And as you can expect from the term, it's
expecting something.
So you're primed to think that this thing's
going to help for this reason.
I'm always really clued in when you have really
obscure off target, off non-expectancy phenomenon
happening.
So in our ibogaine trial, as you mentioned
a minute ago, we had basically everybody quit
drinking coffee for a period of time and none
of them really went into it as most of us
don't, our coffee habit is maybe a concern.
It looks like coffee is protective against
Parkinson's and some other things, so it's
kind of a mixed bag about that, but it's generally
the thing we're the least worried about trying
to deal with, as a generality people are much
more focused on dealing with being overweight
or focused on their alcohol use problem, or
in this case, PTSD and depression and TBI
and all these other things that folks were
worried about.
And so when we started seeing consistent reports
of people stopping their caffeine intake,
it was really a signal for me.
I was like, you know what?
That's really interesting.
I mean, there's probably a bigger systemic
change that's happening.
And what people will tell you, phenomenologically
about this, is it puts a pause in between
stimulus and response.
A phenomenal, and I can't prove this, this
is just what everybody seems to come back
and say it puts a period of time between when
you normally have a trigger to do something
and go do it and it was a habitual action
and really kind of gets into this question
of free will and all this stuff that people
think about, where there's a moment where
instead of making the habitual action, the
person finds themselves in a purely unbiased
choice phenomenon.
And what people who have opiate-use disorder
would say in those scenarios when they would
relapse after ibogaine is they'd say, "You
know what?
I had something about it.
I didn't crave it.
I just wanted to do it or something wanted
to remember," or whatever, but it wasn't this
habitual action.
And they'd go back and they do ibogaine again
after they'd gone back into the addiction
and then they had all the negative consequences
and they say, "You know what?"
And they got back to that choice again and
they're like, "No, it's not worth it anymore.
I'm going to go this way."
But they were able to pause and make those
decisions.
And it sounds like from talking to the various
veterans that have gone through our study
is that they'd approach things like coffee
and they'd be like, "I do this, but do I need
to do it?"
Which is really striking actually, it's not
something that people typically tend to do.
You get into all these habitual actions and
your life is just made up of a lot of habitual
actions and they were able to reevaluate all
those habitual actions and then establish
new patterns.
The drug eventually is going to wear off,
as all drugs eventually do, and you probably
do lay down a level of habituating again.
But if you could, during the period of time
when your brain seems to be pretty plastic,
shift and lay down new patterns that when
the drug wears off assumably, you kind of
lock into that new set of patterns.
And I think that's really interesting and
probably a little bit different than the Ozempics
in the sense that the Ozempics seem to kind
of take away from what folks will say a lot
of the seeking or rewarding aspects of things
with food or whatever.
It's just —
Tim Ferriss: Like cravings.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, cravings.
Whereas this seems to introduce a level of
choice.
What would be very interesting, so you alluded
to this earlier, is you take somebody who
has a pretty significant addiction like this
and you give them an ibogaine sort of drug
and then you think about how do you use something
like an Ozempic to kind of follow on with
that, right?
Where you're able to gate some of it and it's
way out there.
And probably not anything anybody's going
to do anytime soon, but it's an interesting
idea of these are essentially habit-affecting
drugs that we haven't had tools to really
use before, which I think is pretty cool.
Tim Ferriss: And folks who want to dive deeper
into this sort of reopening of, let's call
it critical windows, I mean I'm borrowing
that terminology from Professor Gül Dölen,
but pretty fun stuff to dig into as well,
if you want to scientifically, at least for
the time being, reinforce what a lot of experienced
facilitators have been saying for a long time,
which is the post-period matters a lot.
If you're going to have knee surgery, make
sure you do your rehab.
All right, let's hop to a few other questions.
One is coming back to ibogaine specifically.
The two things that have been of greatest
interest to me with respect to ibogaine are
TBI, right, so if someone has no addiction,
no PTSD, the only issue they have is some
form of TBI, do you think there is a role
for ibogaine so we can place hold that, there's
part two to this question, which is I've heard
reports and I haven't gone into the literature
on this site.
I don't know, maybe this has been explained
somewhere, but I've certainly heard reports
of opiate addicts who have seemed to indicate
that ibogaine or iboga opens a window after
treatment during which they do not seem to
experience much in terms of withdrawal symptoms.
And I want to know what the hell is going
on there if that seems to be observed.
So those are the two questions.
Somebody who just has TBI, do you think there
might be a role for an ibogaine or something
like it, compared to other options, and then
the seeming diminishing or disappearance of
for a period of time, physical withdrawal
symptoms?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it's a little tough
with the cohort that we studied because were,
it was military TBI.
While I understand that the PTSD diagnosis
is pretty ubiquitous in the system, it's probably
true in a fair amount of folks, especially
folks who've been exposed to a lot of combat
related trauma and earlier life trauma that
in our group, it seemed to be there in most
of the participants, so was depression and
anxiety.
And so we haven't studied a pure TBI group.
And so the confound is without studying a
pure TBI group that somehow had, maybe was
a competitor in martial arts or something
like that, right?
Tim Ferriss: Multiple concussions or whatever,
Dr. Nolan Williams: Something like that where
they intended to potentially get hit in the
head.
Tim Ferriss: Probably intended to hit other
people in the head.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Well for sure, but intended
to go into the ring knowing —
Tim Ferriss: You're going to get hit.
Dr. Nolan Williams: That you were probably
going to get hit and that it wasn't, because
the problem is in a lot of these cases, motor
vehicle accidents, there's really high rates
of PTSD in those because there's not an expectation
that you're about to get hit in the head,
but there's probably a population you could
study that's pure traumatic brain injury where
—
Tim Ferriss: Like football players, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, could be football.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of reported depression,
who knows?
There could be a lot of other factors involved,
but —
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, football players
is another great example.
Tim Ferriss: Highly correlated, yeah.
Dr. Nolan Williams: And those guys know they're
going to hit their head in the game probably
at some point.
And so that population where it's more of
a pure TBI population, you could ask that
same question that we asked in this more mixed
population, which is does TBI disability improve?
We saw a dramatic improvement in TBI disability
at the one month mark, less actually right
after it really took a while for it to work,
which is —
Tim Ferriss: If you had to guess, we're two
drinks in, and I'm like, no, just give me
your wild-ass guess mechanistically, what's
going on here?
Dr. Nolan Williams: I mean, it's this symphony,
right?
Which is sounds kind of like maybe even hokey
or a little less direct, but I just think
that there's something about interacting somehow
with multiple different neurotransmitter systems
at the same time that must produce this.
I mean, maybe the GDNF, BDNF alone could do
this.
I'm not saying it can't, but I suspect that
it's some more complex process.
And the problem is we don't have great tools
to evaluate that, but sometimes nature trumps
our human scientific abilities.
And I think that ibogaine certainly is there
in 2023, it's like the story of scurvy.
We associated eventually after a bunch of
weird stuff, we eventually associated eating
oranges with improvement in scurvy, but it
took us another a hundred years to synthesize
vitamin C. And so I think what's so hard about
this scientifically, and to get the scientific
community fully on board with these ideas,
is that we're likely going to figure out this
works before we have any idea on how it works.
Your second question, which is, I'm going
to answer it the same way, is that we don't,
but it's very unique to ibogaine, and you
can take somebody who's going through florid
opioid withdrawals and you can have them not
only have a cessation or stopping of a desire
to go take more heroin or prescription opiates
or whatever it is, but you can have them basically
blunt or completely attenuate the physical
withdrawal symptoms of withdrawing from opiate
use from opiates, right?
Which is diarrhea, like, headache, sweating,
all this stuff that people will go through
when they're going into opiate withdrawals.
And this seems to really knock that out.
It's likely, again, that because it's interacting
with the opioid receptors, it's interacting
with the glutamate system, but it is, to my
knowledge, none of the other psychedelics
can do that, ketamine can't really do that,
so this is a pretty unique thing to ibogaine
that it can pull this off and why I think
it's such an important drug to understand.
I mean, I would argue that because of how
broad ibogaine seems to work across now most
of the major psychiatric diagnoses with the
absence of something like schizophrenia, but
anxiety, depression.
There's traumatic brain injury, multiple different
addiction types.
It's going to behoove the scientific community
to really break down why it does what it does
over the next couple of decades, I think,
and try to really back engineer what it is,
but, yeah, we have no idea.
Tim Ferriss: Outside of the lab and more in
the wild, what are some of the more interesting
things happening related to ibogaine and iboga?
I believe there's something happening in Kentucky?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Yeah, so I've been down to Kentucky to testify
in front of the Opiate Abatement Commission
of Kentucky.
It was myself along with Srini Rao from Atai,
Deborah Mash, who's the CEO of DemeRx, was
at the University of Miami for a while, and
Ken Alper, who was at NYU and is an academic
private practice psychiatrist.
And so there's a guy by the name of Bryan
Hubbard, which, he's a very interesting guy.
He's an attorney by training who has worked
in a bunch of different domains within Kentucky
State government and whatnot.
And he, for one reason or another, has become
completely convinced that the money that ended
up being some of the lawsuit money for some
of the opiate overprescription that happened,
particularly in Kentucky and West Virginia,
but all over the country, should be utilized
for novel therapeutics and not just for more
of the same sort of treatments that we have
available.
The conventional treatments that are available
for opiate-use disorder fall under the realm
of what we think about as replacement therapy.
You're replacing a higher-risk opiate with
a lower-risk opiate, so that's Suboxone, which
contains buprenorphine and methadone, or opiate-blocking
drugs like Naltrexone.
There's a fairly high fail rate on those drugs.
Part of it is psychosocial.
We put people in the right environment.
You could probably drive up the rates of that.
There's also a prescription issue.
You used to have to have a special FDA license
to prescribe it.
I used to have this thing and then recently
that was knocked out.
So everybody with a medical license can prescribe
Suboxone.
And so there's kind of a group of drugs that
can do some work on this, but there's certainly
folks that we would think about as treatment-resistant
opiate-use disorder patients.
And the numbers I'm not going to get into
because debated or whatever, but whatever
those numbers are, it's a good chunk of folks
and they don't really have much to offer.
And so people have thought about lots of different
options for them.
And one of the options is brain surgery.
So in West Virginia, a group of neurosurgeons
are actually doing full on, so there's a surgical
form of neuromodulation called deep brain
stimulation where you can actually put an
implanted device into the reward system.
And also kind of similar to some of these
Wegovy kind of drugs, you can drive down some
of the pleasure around, and this is more theoretical
at this point, but opiate-use, opiates as
well as there's some data out of a couple
of different studies with even weight loss
for stimulating in the reward circuitry.
What's interesting is that there's a one-in-100
risk of a head bleed from that treatment,
and about a third of them end up, it ends
up being a pretty significant head bleed,
right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Dr. Nolan Williams: And so what's really interesting
is you have no one in West Virginia organizing
all these hearings about it.
It's just happening.
They're letting people do the science and
all that stuff.
And I don't disagree with doing that, by the
way.
I think it's a useful thing to explore, and
it may be a solution for this, and this is,
as we described earlier, such a high-risk
phenomenon that a one-in-300 risk is not as
bad.
Tim Ferriss: Is it one-in-300 or one-in-100?
Dr. Nolan Williams: One-in-100 risk of a DBS.
Tim Ferriss: Of a head bleed.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It can be a trivial, just
blood on the tip of the electrode, which is
asymptomatic.
About a third of those people are going to
be in a more, they'll have a complication,
have a real complication, and then you've
got about a one-in-300 risk of a torsades
risk with ibogaine.
And so next door in Kentucky —
Tim Ferriss: Similar odds.
Yeah.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
You've got a similar odd concern, both of
which can be kind of dealt with in the hospital.
I'd argue that the ibogaine risk is probably
a little less actually than the DBS risk if
you just kind of look at everything.
And when they're having these significant
hearings, there's a lot of opinions about
this and a lot of
Tim Ferriss: Shocker!
Dr. Nolan Williams: Right?
And I'm one of the few people that does all
this stuff, so I can kind of, and you juxtapose
this —
Tim Ferriss: That's part of the reason why
we're having this conversation, because you
bridge a bunch of interesting, often separate
worlds.
So anyway.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Thanks, man.
Yeah.
So I went down there and there were a million
questions about the cardiac risk and about
whether or not this should be done and particularly
should state funds be funding this, and there
are various opinions about that.
My opinion and the reason why I was willing
to go down there and support the effort is
there are a subpopulation of people in which
Suboxone, naltrexone, and methadone don't
work, and we need to spend some money on trying
to help those people.
Tim Ferriss: Also working is quote-unquote
"working," has different outcomes if you're
talking about sction therapies as well, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Anyway.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, no, I think you're
totally right.
I think there's, yeah, it's totally, yeah,
is living —
Tim Ferriss: Replacement.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, replacement.
On opiates, if you're having to do this your
whole life, I mean, it's tricky.
You lose your prescription in a flight to
wherever and then now you're in a really bad
place.
And so this idea of instead of replacement
or substitution or whatever, interruption,
which is what ibogaine is going to do, and
I think at some level what DBS is going to
do too, it's going to interrupt that system,
that circuit that's driving the seeking behavior
and be able to reorganize the brain, such
the person approaches the problem in a different
way is a promise that I think everybody wants
to see.
I think the interesting part about this whole
phenomenon down there is from the folks that
are opposed to this is this view that one,
the current treatments are fine or whatever,
and then two, that how could it be that this
extract from a root in an African country
somehow be something that can do what modern
humans and pharma can't do?
And it goes back to what I think is a pretty
hubristic part of the human psyche, which
is that I need to start the fire, I need to
hammer the wheel, I need to, and I think at
some level —
Tim Ferriss: The sort of "not invented here"
kind of thing.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Yeah, right?
And I think the idea that somehow this just
exists, it goes around the psyche in a way
that doesn't really work.
And we saw this with scurvy too, right?
I've spent a lot of time studying scurvy because
I am very interested in this human phenomenon.
There were people called anti-fruiters.
I'm not kidding you, it's a real term.
And they were in the royal societies in the
1750s.
And so we knew from 1498 that folks that were
going around the Horn of Africa and going
to Asia that way, they'd plant citrus trees
all the way there.
So we were doing this and at some point, scurvy
got worse and all that.
And people said, "There's literally no way
that these fruits could be the solution for
this.
Humans have to solve this.
And actually the fruits are probably what's
making it worse."
So James Lind ran the first clinical trial
in the history of humans on scurvy and citrus
fruit where he gave all these various weird
concoctions like poisons, and they were trying
to give people cyanide.
They were trying to give people alcohol mixed
with acid.
This is what they, and so he randomized people
on a ship with scurvy to these various things
in citrus fruit.
And what happened was the citrus fruit receiving
people at the end of the week were taking
care of everybody else, but it took another
a hundred years.
And I think this is meta phenomenon of people
need to feel like they made it in that culture
within that context that this is the latest
and greatest thing.
It needs to be kind of very proximal in time.
It needs to be new, it's got to be the new
thing to be the solution.
And I think that's part of what's going on
in Kentucky from my view of it.
If you look at West Virginia and you just
look at the actual information of what's going
on, you'd probably be more likely to cause,
and I don't think that people should, but
question the brain surgery thing, if you really
get down to it over the ibogaine thing, just
on the risk portfolio and having to have an
implanted device for the rest of your life.
But nobody, there's nothing there.
And it's because we're making this.
Western society is making this really innovative
new treatment that requires a brain surgery
and dah, dah, dah.
And that's totally cool from their perspective.
And I think that we've got to, as a culture
and as a scientific community, really change
the way that we think about evaluating tests
and particularly therapies and look at the
inherent scientific complexity and not the
temporal proximity and the fact that we made
it or whatever, and those sorts of things
that I think drive people to have these misconceptions.
So yeah, Kentucky's really interesting, and
it's really an argument about whether or not
some of this money should be earmarked and
whether or not it should be studied.
I think both of those things are a, "Yes,
we should be."
It's the best candidate that we know about
and the risks are mitigatable and similar
to DBS.
Tim Ferriss: So many facets to this, like
insurance reimbursement, scaling, therapists
availability, or I should say more medical
availability for the duration of stay that
would be required with ibogaine versus, there's
so many facets to all of this in terms of,
say, getting to patient 10,000, whether it's
this DBS implant surgery or ibogaine, there's
so many levels of nuance, but at the basic
science level and the further research that
if, I mean, who am I to say?
But it seems like the cost and severity and
prevalence of the problem is such that the
answer is of course, yes.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Of course it's yes.
I do want to ask you about synthesis specifically,
really diving in because I'm always fascinated
by rate-limiting steps and also unintended
consequences of using different compounds
that occur in nature.
But before we get there, I want to very selfishly
throw a wild card question around IRBs and
funding studies and getting ethical approvals
because I would love to see more studies on
extended fasts in humans, but to my knowledge,
those basically got taken off of the table
if I wanted to try to make the case and fund
some science related to extended fasts in
humans.
Any suggestions?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I mean I think everything's
studiable if the risk benefit ratio is on
the right side of things.
I don't think there's any, I mean at least
at Stanford, I think that's the evaluation
is extended fasts in normal healthy controls.
That would be, but I think if you can make
an argument for some sort of medical psychiatric,
whatever it is, condition that you think that
the benefit of doing that significantly outweighs
the risk.
Tim Ferriss: I think I can make that case.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Then I think you can do
it.
And so it really is just that, right?
It's this ethical, and I agree with it, right?
It's this ethical justification that we're
going to be able to do more good by trying
to do something like this than to do harm.
I mean, if people, a study that would never
go through any IRB is we're going to randomize
people to no motorcycle helmet or motorcycle
helmet and have them do laps around the university.
We pretty much know the answer to that question
and the benefit of knowing in a randomized
control trial way, the benefit of the answer
to that question does not outweigh the risk
at the individual patient or participant level
of participating in a trial like that.
So that trial would never get done.
And so I think that's the way that we have
to look at it.
So if you've got a reason, your reason is
you think that there's going to be some effect
on coronary artery disease or something like
that, or —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I think there are a couple
of different approaches I could take just
in case there's anyone listening who wants
to do this.
And there are extended people study fasting
in animals all the time, but it's for whatever
set of reasons at some point it seems to have
been taken off the table for human subjects.
I mean there is research done, I want to say
up until maybe the '40s and '50s, but then
it kind of vanished.
And I'm very interested in if I had to make
the case, I would probably make some type
of case around what Chris Palmer at Harvard
and other people have called metabolic psychiatry.
So to look at this almost like the accelerated
TMS equivalent of a ketogenic diet for certain
psychiatric conditions, because you see some
incredible results, and Chris has been on
the podcast with, say, ketogenic diet as applied
to conditions like schizophrenia, for instance.
I mean remarkable transformations where people
get off of half a dozen or dozen medications.
And you, I am interested in practical solutions
and especially things that are uncrowded from
the perspective of scientific support, which
for a while has been psychedelics, but certainly
accelerated TMS.
I'm agnostic when it comes to the tools and
I think I'd probably make the metabolic psychiatry
argument, but the fact of the matter is I
also feel like it's been so long since we
applied modern tools and tracking of biomarkers
and so on, everything that we have at hand
now to human fasting, that may not be the
argument that I would use, but certainly there
is that.
Okay.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: So synthesis, there's a great
piece that came out in National Geographic
not too long ago by journalist named Rachel
Nuwer, I think I'm getting the last name right?
N-U-W-E-R.
She also has a great book on MDMA and MDMA-assisted
psychotherapy, the history and implications
that recently came out and she traveled to,
I think it was Gabon, although I think there
is also, I think you can also find iboga in
Cameroon if I'm not mistaken.
And she went on the ground to look at all
the implications of global demand for ibogaine
and iboga and it's very, very nuanced, but
it seems clear, and I wrote a piece a long
time ago on my blog, which was a letter to
users of psychedelics, like a plea for a more
ethical menu of options, something like that
to just point out some of the diminishing
natural supplies for say, peyote, right?
Almost certainly going to go extinct, use
something else, use San Pedro cactus, look
at the growth cycles.
Just don't touch it unless you're part of
a culture that has this as an integral part
of tradition and healing as would be the case
for say, people who are in the Native American
Church and so on.
But iboga, ibogaine can be had in, I guess,
a number of different ways.
Maybe you could speak to the known options
and then looking forward what some of the
most interesting options are for whether it's
extraction or synthesis.
Dr. Nolan Williams: And so there's kind of
the straight extract out of the iboga tree
as you're pointing out, and that one's probably
a pretty big ethical issue because what's
happening, and I think that that National
Geographic article really reflect this is
that there's such a global demand that it
drives the prices up in the peoples that take
ibogaine, iboga and in Gabon in surrounding
countries no longer can access it because
of the high cost, which is the last thing
that you want to have happen.
That's the thing that everybody I think should
be trying to avoid first.
And so what else can you do?
So another way to do this is that there's
another tree in Ghana and other places in
Africa that has voacangine, the Voacanga africana
tree, and it has voacangine, which is a very
similar but not identical alkaloid to ibogaine.
It's actually not even a controlled substance.
So voacangine is not on the controlled substances
list, and it's not as much of an issue.
There's not really a current medicinal usage
of voacangine or utilization of that within
those cultures that have these trees.
Tim Ferriss: It's also more commercially cultivated,
if I'm not mistaken, for maybe fragrances
or something.
I can't recall the commercial use.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, and it's pretty
ubiquitous too.
I mean, I've heard that it's not just in Africa,
it's in some of Central and South America,
and so you can extract the voacangine and
then you can do this simple chemical step
to get it to ibogaine.
So to do a synthesis pathway of ibogaine from
de novo, it's like 26 plus steps or something
like that.
But this is the last step before it's ibogaine
from voacangine, and so it's really pretty
straightforward to do that, but you're still
talking about a botanical, right?
You're still talking about essentially growing
a plant to derive a chemical out of the plant.
So the other way to think about it is you
do a full chemical synthesis and people have
looked at that and tried to do it.
It's very hard to though, because ibogaine
has two chiral centers, so it has the potential
for four stereoisomers, and that chemistry
is complicated.
And so full synthesis is a tricky process.
My suspicion is that whether it be biosynthesis
or straight full synthesis, but there's got
to be a way to make this that avoids trees
eventually.
I think it's better for the environment.
It's going to be more scalable, is going to
be something that standard pharma is going
to want to see happen, to really be able to
use it.
But there's still some time to get from A
to B as far as that goes.
So I think it's not a done deal.
It's not completely figured out yet.
Tim Ferriss: So bridging from that, I mean,
this is actually a completely separate question,
but also raises some sustainability, ethical
questions, 5-MeO-DMT.
So five methoxy DMT.
So first of all, I would really implore people,
I'll link to this in the show notes as well,
read the blog post that I put together.
So the 5-MeO-DMT, I mean it's present in quite
a few different plants, different nuts.
Most people who have heard it in the zeitgeist
to know it within the context of Bufo alvarius,
there are other scientific names for this
toad, the Sonoran Desert Toad.
And that has turned into a huge mess in terms
of cartel harvesting and over harvesting from
these poor toads.
It can be synthesized.
There are ways to synthesize that.
Hamilton Morris has beat the drum about this.
To his credit, there is no, people are not
going to like this, but there is no documented
indigenous use of the Sonoran Desert Toad,
Ken Nelson, look it up, in the '80s, produced
a pamphlet after testing God knows how many
things.
Brilliant amateur biochemist.
But nonetheless, it is very, very, it is interesting
and appealing on a whole number of levels.
A lot of people are trying to commercialize
it because at least in Earth time, it is a
short experience.
So that's going to 10 to 20 minutes, 10 to
15 minutes.
So from a business model perspective, I understand
the appeal much like I understand the appeal
of the newly branded psychoplastogens, right?
Psychedelics with the content/mind-altering
aspects as removed as possible.
We might come back to that, but my question
related to this is not so much on the production
side because people can read about that separately.
And I think it's important for people to read
about.
It's more of practical use following IGA administration,
I believe I've heard people describe its use
on what some people call the gray day following
administration.
Could you speak to this, because I'm trying
to discern for myself how important or critical
it is from a therapeutic outcomes perspective
versus being a business differentiator?
Does that make sense?
This is something we put a nice set of icing
on top of the cake and that includes this
what can often be a sublime experience, not
always for people, it can be destabilizing
for some folks, but in the form of 5-MeO-DMT.
So what's your take on this?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, I mean, so we specifically
made sure that folks weren't getting a second
kind of confounding drug on top of the ibogaine
to figure out what the ibogaine effects were
in isolation.
And as I described earlier, we had extremely
remarkable effects in the absence of doing
the 5-MeO.
I think what people say about this, the 5-MeO,
is that it just takes the edge, at minimum
it just seems to take the edge off the gray
day, which is a day that happens for not everybody
that takes ibogaine, but a fair percentage
of people such that there's a name for it,
where people for some reason end up having
kind of a bad day in and around like day two,
three, where they really have a hard time
and then it goes away the next day.
Tim Ferriss: Hard time meaning depressive
symptoms —
Dr. Nolan Williams: For some people.
Tim Ferriss: What is hard?
Okay, what makes it hard?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Anxiety.
Tim Ferriss: Anxiety.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, like anhedonia,
low motivation, sadness.
I think probably what's going on is there
was a serious kind of flooding of your CNS
with a whole host of effects from this drug,
and then the brain's then kind of reacting
to that, and then it seems to rebound out
on its own without the 5-MeO.
But it sounds like, from what I've heard,
the 5-MeO bridges people out of that, so they
don't have to really have to experience that
feeling.
Now the question would be, does it do something
else beyond that that's useful?
And we have no idea.
I suppose what we could have done, or maybe
what we could do in a subsequent study is
to just randomize people to getting no 5-MeO
after or 5-MeO.
And we could actually answer that question.
Does it have an effect on the long-term?
It's hard because there's a floor effect of
just the profound improvements that we saw
just from ibogaine.
So you'd have to, my guess is that the statistics
would tell you that you have to do a pretty
large sample to be able to see something if
it's there with 5-MeO just because everybody's
flooring out just with ibogaine.
Tim Ferriss: When you say flooring out, does
that mean that the amplitude of the effect
is so great that, just in terms of seeing
a large percentage improvement over the ibogaine,
you'd need to see something great?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: What do you mean by flooring
out?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah.
So essentially we're seeing people drop down
within that normal range.
Tim Ferriss: On the assessments.
Dr. Nolan Williams: On the assessments.
So you'd need to see — and people are going
into the range of a score of five, six, something
like that on various scales.
The PTSD scales, the depression scales between
the normal range, and so you'd have to zero
people out with a 5-MeO, essentially.
Or the other thing that it may do, which nobody
knows probably, is whether or not it makes
some of these folks who were, and you'll see
in the paper, there are a couple of people
that relapsed at the month mark.
Maybe it helps the durability on some people.
It could do those things.
So I'm not saying that it doesn't have a benefit.
It would be a hard study to deal with, and
I think from a purist, I want to see this
go through the FDA and kind do the FDA things
and see if we can get the first drug through
the process.
I don't want to say it's a distraction from
a US scientific regulatory strategy standpoint,
but it's definitely something that would add
complexity.
So I think at the level of clinics, they're
doing this in Mexico and they have free-range
to use these substances.
I don't think it's, on the face of it, like
a terrible thing to do.
I think it makes sense why they're doing it.
Tim Ferriss: Do you really think that?
I guess just to push on that a little bit,
I'm like, okay, so people have a hard day,
but it's known that this is a phenomenon so
they could prep people for the possibility
that they would experience this hard day if
they're not somehow edging into dangerous
territory where they're likely to self-harm.
5-MeO-DMT, I have some experience with it.
I understand the appeal, it's like satcitananda,
et cetera, but it's not risk-free.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Well, you're strapping
yourself to a rocket.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
That is a big, big gun, right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Which is not to malign anyone
who is using this in a clinical setting, but
it's not risk free.
I have friends who are very, very experienced
psychonauts.
We're talking like a hundred plus reps with
things like ayahuasca who have been pretty
much even keel with their various experiments
and been knocked pretty sideways for non-trivial
periods of time by 5-MeO-DMT.
Maybe that's just the sample set that I'm
dealing with.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, it's an interesting
— and I totally agree with you.
Medicine is a discipline and a profession
of risk mitigation and risk benefit ratios
and everything.
Anybody that would proclaim themselves to
be a physician scientist that doesn't believe
that isn't seeing it as it is.
Everything that I do is some sort of risk
mitigation exercise where I'm looking at this
thing has these risks, but this person has
these inherent risks, and how do you square
all that?
I think to your point, it would totally make
sense if the person was in such a bad place
in the grade A that you were worried about
them.
I think there's a justification there.
It seems that they do have some general experience
that this was helpful to getting folks out.
The reality is that we're really not going
to know much of anything, and a lot of this
is going to be in the realm of anecdote until
we do the trials in the US and really thoroughly
document everything that happens with this
draw, with ibogaine, with fibromyalgia, which
as you know, people are trying to put through
trials and commercialize that.
So I think there's a moment where we'll be
able to rectify all of this and figure it
out.
I agree with you too that I think that where
MDMA may be a substance that certainly not
everybody could use, but a decently broad
population-based drug that a fair amount of
the population that had PTSD could go after.
I think that these substances are more constrained
to a smaller population where the risk benefit
is right for them.
So absolutely, it's a tricky moment.
I think we know just enough to be dangerous
in some places, and we got to get through
this just enough to be dangerous moment to
the we know how to not be dangerous moment
as a culture and do that with the scientific
process.
Tim Ferriss: Much earlier you were laying
out psychiatry 1.0, 2.0, 3.0.
I'd love for you to feel free to speculate,
right?
It's going to be speculation, but putting
aside the — I know it's hard to do, but
shepherding stuff in its simplest form, cleanest
form through the FDS, etc.
But what might psychiatry 4.0 look like in
the sense that — for instance, something
that's on my mind, and I'll keep it short,
is as I understand it at a very primitive
level, the way that some of the accelerated
TMS protocols work from a hardware perspective
is you're kind hitting nodes at the exterior
of the hub and triangulating in a way to hit
what you're trying to hit.
But perhaps you could use, for instance, in
my conversation with Nora Volkow of NIDA,
she's talking about focused ultrasound.
So maybe you use that to hit the deeper structures
directly.
You hit the nucleus accumbens or whatever
it might be.
Then related to that, if we're talking about
Freud and so on, focusing on content, and
then you've got this sort of neurotransmitter
focus, oh, it's a serotonin issue, and then
now you have the electroceutical kind of structural
nuance and experimentation.
But it seems like these things aren't necessarily
wrong.
They're just, at least if we're looking at
the content, the molecules incomplete.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It's incomplete.
That's right.
Tim Ferriss: But if you talk to a lot of these
guys who go through, and gals, but a lot of
these operators of men who go through the
ibogaine experience, they will — and maybe
there's a visibility bias because they can't
see what the hell's going on in their head
from a chemical perspective, but they can
remember the content, but a lot of people
attribute the therapeutic effects to much
of the content.
There's reconciliation and so on.
So what might psychiatry 4.0 look like?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, that's a great question.
We have a paper coming out soon where we're
actually trying to use neurostimulation to
change trait hypnotizability to make people
more suggestible transiently, and it's probably
an ability to zero in on specific content
and manipulate that content through circuit
based intervention.
That's a pure speculation, but I'll give you
an anecdotal kind of case report example.
So there was a patient who got similar sort
of deep brain stimulation approach that I
was describing earlier that they're looking
at in West Virginia for addiction.
That individual received deep brain stimulation,
I think in Europe, I think for OCD.
He had a normal musical taste.
He listened to whatever the range of standard
artists, and then he got his deep brain stimulation
and he became obsessed with Johnny Cash.
Totally sold all of his —
Tim Ferriss: I didn't see that coming.
All right.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, totally sold all
of his other albums and listened to Johnny
Cash.
The batteries for the brain stimulators will
wear out after time and you need a new one.
It's decently common that if the person's
doing pretty well, then they will forget to
come in and then all of a sudden their battery's
dead and then they'll have a re-emergence
of symptoms.
So this gentleman did.
So I think it was his OCD and his OCD got
worse again, and he fell out of favor with
Johnny Cash and threw away all of his Johnny
Cash albums and started listening to whatever
he was listening to before, went in and got
a battery changed.
The battery was put back in.
Tim Ferriss: He's like, "For fuck's sake.
I've got to go back to the shop and buy my
Johnny Cash!"
Dr. Nolan Williams: That's what he did.
So just like we don't really understand how
ibogaine works, we really don't understand
what happened there.
It was a very illustrative case, and I love
talking about that case because it gets into
this area that I think people are really worried
about right now, about specific content manipulation.
I don't think we can do that.
We don't have the tools to do that.
We have these broad tools that basically change
the lens of the world that you look through.
I can change your brain in such a way that,
for some people, they're going to see rose
color glasses where they saw blue before or
whatever.
Tim Ferriss: It's like, I can give you a different
set of glasses to watch the movie, but I can't
change the movie directly.
Dr. Nolan Williams: You can't change the movie
directly.
My suspicion is that we're going to edge into
a world where maybe we can change the movie.
That's where it starts to get both very interesting
and very ethically complicated.
That story about Johnny Cash, that doctor
had no intention of doing that because nobody
knows how to do that.
Maybe they played Johnny Cash in the OR, maybe
not.
They didn't report that in the case report,
but there's no clear sense of why that happened
either.
Is this the first song that was playing in
the hospital and he woke up and his brain,
the reward system just kind of attached to
it or whatever?
But it's one of these things where we're going
to get to a place of sophistication.
I think we're going to be able to do that.
What happens in medicine is, I see it is we
are always redefining what's illness.
So it used to be that high blood pressure
was 150 over 100 or something, and then it
was 140 over 90 and then it's 130 over 80,
and now it's 125 over 75 or whatever it is.
It's not that the illness has changed.
It's our definition of illness changed.
So my suspicion is that as we have enough
tools to be able to knock out these major
mental illnesses, which were effectively end
states, at the end of the day.
We let the system go all the way to this kind
of completely semi-functional end state where
people have semi volition and they're kind
of stuck in these mindsets and these behaviors.
If we can figure out what that is and we have
ways of intervening sooner in that process,
and we have emerging tools that can help you
with this sort of content targeting manipulation
sort of thing, then I think you're going to
be talking about much more specific sort of
interventions.
That's very sci-fi though.
It's not something that I think there's even
a hint of.
I wouldn't even know how to tell you how to
do that now.
Our one shot on goal is just to move around
this brain trait.
We do have a study with Raag Airan where we're
actually packaging ketamine into nano particles,
infusing them into through an IV into the
bloodstream, and then using ultrasound to
open the nano particle ketamine and drop ketamine
just in the cingulate, in the area that we
were talking about earlier in this case, in
pain patients, because it's easy to measure
pain scales and reactivity.
But what I think will be really interesting
with that is if you could take that same technology
and start to drop various psychedelics into
specific brain regions and you can do a behavior
mapping exercise, what's necessary and sufficient
to produce the clinical improvement, what's
necessary and sufficient to produce the trip.
I think that's going to be way more important
than modifying the molecules, because it's
like a confound.
We're not really answering the question of
does tripless ibogaine work?
Because it's not ibogaine.
It's just some other thing.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Dr. Nolan Williams: But what we really want
to know is does tripless ibogaine work because
we just put it in the amygdala or just into
the cingulate or something like that?
That in isolation isn't sufficient to produce
the trip, but it's sufficient to produce a
therapeutic effect.
I think if we can pull that off, we're going
to start next year on that, that's going to
be super cool because it's going to give us
the ability to have more of these questions.
You could even think about it if you had a
long-acting anesthetic where you had somebody
with pretty pronounced psychosis, schizophrenia
symptoms coming in, and you're able to shut
down their amygdala for a couple of days with
an anesthetic just in the amygdala and nowhere
else.
They're totally awake, they're still with
you, but their fear response or into the cingulate,
their kind of salience of the environment
response, goes down because you're able to
kind of temporarily shut it off, but you're
not having to give a whole body whole brain
anesthetic where you're putting somebody into
a medical coma or something.
You're just shutting down this one area.
So it's an interesting —
Tim Ferriss: Which you could potentially do
through neuromodulation and not pharmaceutical,
right?
Dr. Nolan Williams: You can, but even with
— so people have tried to do that with deep
brain stimulation.
You can actually do a jamming signal in certain
areas and shut it down too.
But it ends up being — and that may be the
long-term solution, you're using drugs like
focal drugs to test it.
It's a commitment.
It's not something you do in an emergency,
but you could in theory do this in the ER.
You could take somebody that was acutely psychotic,
you could put an anesthetic that could shut
down that system for transiently for a couple
of days, and you could get them more on board
with thinking about what the long-term solution
is when the fear system isn't in place as
much.
All total speculation.
It's not something I have any direct data
to support, but it's definitely interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Let's push it into a little bit
more sci-fi because it's fun.
Also a lot of things that start in sci-fi
end up in sci.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Right, true.
Tim Ferriss: So to speak.
You look at Snow Crash by Neal Stephenson
and he's very good.
There are many, many examples, but do you
think you could change handedness, hand dominance?
Dr. Nolan Williams: That one would be hard.
I think it's possible to do that at childhood.
We do do this in stroke.
We do this constraint therapy sort of stuff
where you actually constrain — if you have
a big stroke where you have on one side of
the brain, you have a pretty devastating stroke
where people can't move their arm and all
that good stuff, or they have minimal movement
of their arm and then they have an intact
side, that's totally fine.
You actually constrain the intact side and
force the person to use the affected side
to drink water or to write or whatever.
What you're trying to do is to reorganize
the neural system in such a way to where there's
more cross-functional attribution of that
side.
So we have some evidence there's ways to do
that.
There's kids who need corpus callosotomies
in various different, pretty significant,
like, say, epilepsy surgeries when they're
really, really young, like one year old, two
years old, three years old, whatever.
When you look at those cases, it can lose
a pretty substantial part of their brain from
whatever surgery they needed to deal with
their problem or if they had a trauma or whatever.
They can reorganize the system to be able
to reallocate resources to be able to do bilateral
sort of functions.
So it's mostly that the brain gets fixed.
The interesting thing about this idea of critical
periods and whether or not, and maybe what
ibogaine is doing and whether or not you can
make a more plastic brain is this idea that
if you could bring the brain to a more juvenile
state, then you could probably neuro-rehab
it better.
That's going to be, I think one of the questions
that'll come out of the data that we're going
to present is how far can this go?
We saw people go from mild to moderate TBI
disability to not on average, which is awesome
and never heard of.
But if you keep pushing on that, how far could
you go with something like that?
That's going to be a question that I don't
have an answer for, but at least there's a
signal there to look.
That's kind of part of what I like about the
general work that I try to do is I like to
be relatively disrupting and I like to be
in spaces where nobody else is working.
I start to not like it when everybody's doing
it.
So I'm like always now, "Where am I going?"
I'm always looking for the thing where nobody's
really in that space studying it.
I always like it when people think — if
people think it's really weird, it's a positive
signal that I need to do it kind of thing.
So I think certainly this area of using psychedelic
drugs to try to treat neuro deficits is not
something that a whole lot of people are really
looking into right now.
So it's pretty curious and hopefully we can
ask some of those questions.
Tim Ferriss: One aspect of the accelerated
TMS in terms of — case reports may be too
strong word — anecdotal reports that I found
interesting, is it seems like some folks report
increased visual acuity or color contrast.
I found that very interesting for a few reasons.
Number one is that it's very commonly reported,
say if you're on lower doses or higher doses,
but let's just say low to moderate doses of
certain psychedelics.
It's sort of like the dial on your HD visual
perception is set forward a few clicks.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: The flowers sparkle just a little
bit more.
You notice details you would otherwise not
notice.
The reason I'm bringing this up, that raises
a lot of questions, but I'm bringing that
up specifically because there are athletes
who have talked about the performance enhancing
benefits of some types of psychedelic use.
I think Aaron Rodgers would be one example
of this, although I don't want to say it's
sort of in session use.
It's I think more longer term implications.
However, there are people, certainly I know
athletes who have used these things to enhance
their perceptual faculties, which then leads
me to wonder and almost assume that neuromodulation
will be used as a very hard to detect means
of performance enhancement in sports.
It's hard for me to see how that would not
be the case with people who are willing to.
I think there was some type of poll done at
one point.
It's like, would you be willing to take a
drug that would guarantee you to get a gold
medal, but it would reduce your lifespan by
five or 10 years?
The answer for this thing could be all made
up, who knows?
But I remember the report supposedly indicating
that the yes answer was very, very high percentage
of respondents.
So if they're looking at something that has
a lower risk profile and is basically going
to be impossible for the world anti-doping
association to track, why wouldn't they try
it?
Dr. Nolan Williams: Absolutely.
I'll tell you, we've had a number of patients
who've gone through and they remitted really
early, so they lost all their symptoms really
early in the week.
So day one or two.
Then by day three, they've zeroed out.
Then Thursday, day four or five, they're coming
in and they're saying, "You know what?"
I remember this one guy, he was like, "I was
driving by the beach and I saw the sun setting
or whatever it was, and I wanted to stop and,
for whatever reason, just sit on the beach,
and I don't normally do that."
Then he described how he was completely present
in the present moment and able to just be
there and present and was watching the water
for an hour.
He said, "I've never been able to do that
before, but I used to do these mindfulness
courses that I couldn't understand, and it
fell a lot like that.
I went and found my book and it sounded like
I was having this kind of totally present
mindful moment."
I've had a ton of folks come back and tell
me this.
So if they remit really early and we keep
treating them, we treat them through and they
get to this kind of more — now that we've
had folks come through for this and folks
come through for psychedelic treatments, it
looks like day three, four, five out of a
psilocybin experiment where the person's no
longer having any trip, but they're just calm
and peaceful and pretty relaxed and present,
and it's very similar to that.
So I think that you're probably getting a
similar or the same state there.
I would assume a state where a lot of good
performance can happen from you really are
truly in this moment not thinking about the
present or the future.
I've had a lot of folks actually offer, and
at some point we need to do this, but offer
various philanthropic gifts for me to run
trials on athlete performance.
Tim Ferriss: I knew it.
I knew it.
Of course.
Dr. Nolan Williams: One of our donors said
to me, "I will give you the money if you will
take me and all of my group of friends."
Tim Ferriss: All my post-finance guy triathlete
friends.
Dr. Nolan Williams: It is basically that.
We cycle every morning and randomize us to
sham our active stimulation before we get
on the bikes and look at it.
He's like, "The reason why this is good is
because we make the same exact times and everybody
knows their times, and can you change this?"
There's a little bit of evidence for this.
It was a paper that was published a couple
of years ago where they took people and taught
them to do complex motor tasks like hand tasks
where it's like tap digit 1, 3, 5, 1, 3, 5,
1, 3, 5, and then interspersed it with 2,
4, 1, 3, 5, 2, 4, like that.
It's like a complex kind of multi-step finger
task.
If you prime the motor learning area before
you do that, you can cut the speed of acquisition
in half compared to the people that had sham.
Tim Ferriss: That's non-trivial.
Seems non-trivial.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah.
So it's interesting.
There's some really early preliminary data
to suggest that you could potentially improve
performance with neurostim.
The thing about it is that if you could pull
something — if you really could have something
that people have been thinking about TMS as
a treatment for insomnia, others for acute
anxiety.
If you could come up with something that you
could kind of put the brakes on a couple of
different symptomatologies and you could make
— maybe it's a TMS device, maybe it's another
technology.
You can make it something you could bring
home, then you'd have the ability to have
this kind of full service sort of process
for dealing with things.
I think trying to treat depression and isolation
or something like that, you're never going
to be able to scale, I think one treatment
alone.
But if we get to a place where we can use
this for a lot of different functions and
actually the hypnotizability stuff, drive
people up to be able to receive information
better or study better or whatever, do motor
tasks better and then turn it off and flip
it on to sleep mode.
You had a level of more control over your
brain than just your own volition.
It's your volition plus your volition to do
these things, then I think it's very interesting.
It's also very sci-fi though.
We are not anywhere close to knowing we can
do that yet.
Tim Ferriss: Not anywhere close.
Yeah, not anywhere close yet.
But fun food for thought at the very least.
Nolan, one more time.
Where can people find your lab online?
Dr. Nolan Williams: So it's bsl.stanford.edu.
It's the Stanford Brain Stimulation Lab.
Tim Ferriss: Great.
Any other websites you'd like to point people
to?
Dr. Nolan Williams: No, I think that one's
the place to go.
Tim Ferriss: That's home base.
Anything else you'd like to say before we
wind to a close?
Any comments?
Public complaints?
Dr. Nolan Williams: No, it's been super fun.
I think you've definitely gotten yourself
quite up to speed and kind of right in the
center of a lot of the pulse of this and both
on the neurostim side and the —
Tim Ferriss: Psychedelic pulse.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, yeah.
So appreciate the knowledge coming in and
your interests, and I appreciate the ability
to have a conversation around these topics.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for saying that.
I really have enjoyed delving into this field.
You've been incredibly helpful as a resource
and a sanity check since I get all excited
about things and sometimes can fly off the
rails, but it's been so much fun to engage
with this burgeoning, I think hopefully soon
to be dramatically expanded, field of experimentation,
especially given the remission rates and the
durability.
The reason I first began exploring this was
I saw a friend's family completely transformed,
and the before and after was just truly unbelievable.
One of the most unbelievable transformations
I've ever seen in my life.
It happened quickly.
I think it was about day three.
Many, many failed interventions, really critical
situation, lots of self — harm, and it was
just like Ctrl Z undo and back to the person
they used to be.
It's been durable with, I want to say, let's
call them single day boosters, maybe once
a quarter or once every six months.
I think it's now been durable, I want to say
probably a year and a half, which is just
phenomenal.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Cool.
Tim Ferriss: So I appreciate the work you
do.
I appreciate you being the last man standing
on the scientific bachelorette, and I suspect
that'll happen again.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, probably.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks for taking the time for
the conversation, man.
Dr. Nolan Williams: Yeah, thank you.
Tim Ferriss: Look forward to watching what
you do in the future.
And for everybody listening, we will link
to everything we discussed in the show notes,
including Nolan's lab at tim.blog/podcast.
Until next time, be a little bit kinder than
is necessary to others and to yourself, and
thanks for tuning in.